so
come on
there's
is
three two one
bruh
come on let's go
get out take it out
let's go
oh
i feel like it's too obvious to take queen
here but i feel like that's the right move
oh okay check first then take queen
brother i'm looking at all my [
__ ] pieces connect what about it
that's not it [ __ ] are you guys stupid
oh no dude
i need i need caffeine give me a second hold up
i said [ __ ] are you stupid
closed captioning
our match will start in about two minutes i
think so you know what i gotta play our song
i'm ready to get shivers baby
oh let's go
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to blog champs three our first match of
the day going down in two minutes versus mick
the fortnite gamer and nico lol the hunter
thief content creator tick tocker here we go
all right sorry ladies and gentlemen it seems
like we have a technical difficulty it is 12
o'clock and the match has not begun please hold
on tight maybe go grab a snack get a drink now's
a great time to maybe go use the bathroom as
you figure out what's happening uh production
he's filming a tick tock she's gonna be
late i got the shooters what the [ __ ] okay
welcome everyone to poc champs three presented by
grip6 and i have finally as you can see managed to
replace gotham chat by a much better commentator
big brain lady thank you so much for joining us
cutie cinderella hi i'm excited to be here
don't tell levy i took his spot he doesn't know
i think he will not notice he had to go to the
dentist so we are filling in but i think your
sense of humor is much better and your chest moves
too will definitely demonstrate that you are in
the right place box jumps to participant cutie
cinderella here to commentate on some of the big
clashes of today including the second match
that will involve ludwig cutie your thoughts
on that upcoming match that we announced as the
battle for your heart because code miko said that
maybe if she beats ludwig she could be
perhaps your future date true miko has
had a crush on me for a very long time uh i've
tried everything to keep her away from me but
i i did have to agree to that so whoever wins that
will get dinner with me the stakes are high let's
take a look at the format of the tournament park
term three the players are split into four groups
we are still in the group stage the final clashes
of the group stage there's a double round robin
with 10 minutes and the five second increments
per move a win in the match is three points in
case it's a time we're gonna go to an armageddon
and two points for the winner 1.4 the one losing
the armageddon match afterwards the knockout stage
will begin that's coming out in a few days and a
big reminder of course on the big prices they
have some amazing prices here for the group
stage as well as for the championship bracket and
a consolation bracket and also the fact that many
of the players have already offered their prices
in advance to charity we have a community outreach
throughout the tournament chess.com is going
to match donations up to a hundred thousand
dollars you can use the comment exclamation mark
charity in the chat click on the link in order to
donate and chess.com will match your donations
as well as the participants prices are matched
by chess.com and all go to the 16 charities
chosen by the participants here are some of
the charities chosen cutie did you have any word
in which charity ludwig was going to donate to
no he he's a big fan of no kid hungry
he's done a lot of stuff with them
he is often hungry so he just wants to help
anybody who could be hungry that's a great
cause to support yeah we really appreciate all
these amazing creators streamers gamers actors
to come together for such a good cause and also
to show us our amazing their amazing chess moves
let's see how the standings are looking so far
in group a star dosh and benji fishy are both on
six points and cutie today they are facing each
other how do you see that match going down today
i think benji is scary i'm scared i've never been
more afraid of a fortnight kid um and i am often
afraid of fortnite kids and uh seems scary he's so
good he is so good and he's like training behind
the scenes and he's been he's been training for
like a month and that's very impressive in group
d we have ludwig on three points who is playing
today against code miko so if ludwig wins he will
catch moist critical in the first place is there a
big rivalry between charlie and ludwig i think um
i think it's this weird like big brother complex
like ludwig has always had a little bit of a crush
on charlie and so i guess that's not what you
do with your big brother typically people don't
have crushes on their big brother i guess we're
all different but anyway i think it'd be good
if he beat him i think that's all he's looking
for he would like to beat him he would like to
you know prove that he is better at chess at least
than charlie makes perfect sense and that's what
nico said during her interview that today is
going to be a fight between 100 thieves and tsm
nico facing myth these are our upcoming clashes if
we bring up the starting times we are starting the
first match a bit later because we had to jump
in instead of mr gotham chess um and hikaru we
are filling big boots here cutie but i think you
are ready for the challenge i'm not sure if i am
i think it'll be easy i think um you know i think
i'm just as good as hikaru and you're just as
funny as levi so it should be should be the same
thing thank you yeah no one will notice we are
not the same people that they were promised that
they were on screen so we are just moments away
from the first game between nico and myth
i wonder if we already have nico with us we
were watching the stream of myth earlier he's
got some banger music there as his preparation
i am a little confused where um i usually you know
when i show up to these chess events i usually
have my women gm title i'm a little confused where
is that yeah i'm just exactly i i thought i earned
it you know of course yeah i think it's a it's
just a typo on the layout because they thought
that was levi's spot and he's clearly yeah that
makes sense that makes sense and to everyone
um don't worry i'm here to represent those of us
who just can't seem to get better at chess that's
not true lady you have improved so much i i
always say whenever i talk about cutie you
were one of the most impressive participants when
it came to pogchamps too because you started out
as someone who only knew how to pieces
move then you took a couple of lessons
you started the puzzle ground you kept on playing
also in your spare time and you improved so much
from match to match you were really one of those
participants that made the biggest progress from
one match to the next one and it's only a few
days in between matches oh well you're nice i
think uh i think if you look at these two there's
there's a slight difference in energy i've noticed
i've noticed already i'm curious to see if this
will affect their gameplay just looking at them
i think nico is missing waking up i wonder
she'll be streaming too i don't see her
live yet so maybe today she will skip streaming
i don't know if you heard cutie but she basically
took one of the last flights out of texas she
had no power no clean water and that was their
condition for a couple of days oh we have the
first moves on the board i think if we refresh
the board hopefully it will show oh if we click
on the list there we go there we go there we go
mika playing with the white pieces in this first
game and she has a very unique opening i don't
know if you have heard of this opening cutie it's
called the bird's opening when you push the f-pawn
at the very start to f4 she's playing so we're
playing fast holy moly they're both playing fast
they're both over the 10-minute mark exactly
i feel like nico always plays this fast she
she said in one of the interviews that she's
impatient i understand that needs to make a
move and move and move well i wonder about
miss uh why is she not taking a bit longer
oh interesting that pawn is just no it's not
well we're going to get used to me calling
things incorrectly nova is because that's what
many of the viewers will be looking at and it's
a great question is the e3 pawn hanging at the
moment not because it's guarded by the c1 bishop
but it's a great setup for myth he's the one
with less experience here nico has played more
games than anyone almost in the field and miss
only started playing chess recently he finds
another strong move knight to d5 attacking
the pawn on e3 that you are looking at
let's listen in if we can hear his
thought process or he's just very focused
oh that's silent for me for now yes i don't
know if he has music or if he's just talking or
i i i mean talking in his head he says clearly not
talking he is not talking i know that brain cells
are talking to each other yes so we we normally
have a myth with some vibe background music
amazing beats but today he went on full
silence not talking extremely focused
drops the bishop back to d6 his piece setup
is looking nice but some of the
pieces are unprotected the d5 knight
and the f5 bishop are unprotected and nico is
trying to take advantage of it oh he said a word
dark we can just guess it means we can just guess
we can yeah we can guess his words i think he said
cereal and he's just really hungry and
he knew if he ate today he'd be fine
i understand myth we're all with you it could
be it could be the kids cookies coming up next
knight to c3 good move by nico developing the
knight and they keep playing really fast jazz
rook 28 is another good move um i wonder though
if nico will find a way to attack the f5 bishop
and so she does it the knight jumps but it's
the rook that is attacking the bishop on f5
will miss see it do you think that he
notices that even though it's a night move
the bishop too is in danger because of the
rook of nico i think i don't think he'll
realize i don't think he'll realize i think he
is going to move the knight yep just like that
about to take on e5 which is all right for now
since he has captured a piece but but if he uses
yeah if he moves that rook then oh well she's good
she can take i don't mind that oh she missed it
i think oh yes sorry i was seeing it
uh with a bit of a time difference
uh she hasn't noticed yet that the bishop on f5 is
hanging the rook could take it she's attacking the
the rook on a8 but now if the rook moves that will
attack the bishop on b7 i don't know queen trade
or not myth what do you think he moves the rook
that's a good move now both bishops are hanging
and queen trade we love one of those mm-hmm
why
oh interesting oh no nico didn't spot
the hanging it's gonna be it's gonna be
bishop to d4 check by myth is a really strong move
because now he could take the bishop of nico for
free yes check me checkmate uh maybe not jackman
just yet but the bishop the bishop is hanging
the bishop of nico was dead but now he
says
the realization that two of which is
regarding this he had no clue now i wonder
would it be a good move to bring the bishop on f4
up to c7 and do a little bit of us is that a fork
absolutely two rocks a great move cutie you
are right that the bishop could capture the
pawn and attack both rooks i wonder if niko will
spot it after a potential trade on e4 myth could
take the bishop on e4 or try to take on c3 as well
there's still quite many options for him as well
to try to take things up no i should have just
taken that from there oh okay so he stops that
he did stop it and is attacking the e4 bishop
navi two of his pieces as well as the bishop
on d4 could capture on c3 so oh nico didn't
see that it's not enough to bring the rook in
because there's a thing called remove
the defender that if myth realizes that
his bishop can capture the knight then the e4
bishop will not have enough defending pieces
do you think do you think that's something
that myth will see right now i don't think
he will it's quite complex because you you need
to first discover that as of now the bishop on
e4 is fine but the only reason why it's fine is
because the knight is is helping he didn't see it
um but even like this his move to is quite
a tricky one he captures that pawn which
was defending the knight and if the knight
moves away the bishop is still in trouble
this is still challenging nico made
a move that hangs the bishop on e4
but now we'll miss i think see it i think nico's
goal is really just to get that c7 pawn i don't
know i don't know where else she's going with that
uh oh yeah the bishop is gone now so it's equal
material from a piece up now myth has taken the
bishop and is up upon threatening knight to f to
check among other options this was a great move
by myth because he also could have captured the
bishop with the rook but then the rook would have
been in trouble after knight takes night i don't
know if we can show that position for a moment uh
cute if you go back one move before myth took on
e4 let me know yes so if rook takes bishop if the
black rook takes the the bishop on e4 there's an
intermediate move for white knight nightclubster
knight captures knight and that undermines the
defense of the rook with a check that's lovely
look at that he didn't fall for it he took the
light on e4 he didn't fall for this and now the
game is wide open it could be anyone's game oh
no i do this all the time we want to recap anyway
i think it i think it was good this is what you
missed you guys um in case you were sad uh we're
just going to skip to where they are though
because you've seen it it's very cool it's
really cool this is the current position and
wait a second knight f6 no okay no oh we need to
uh oh go back do you see where the moves are so we
are still in our analysis and right there should
be a button for um that's like a refresh button
um there it is yes there we go yeah great so this
is the current position and nico has played bishop
to e3 i wonder i wonder if you click refresh
again will it show that she has made one more move
um oh our board decided to give up on us for a
moment so we will refresh yeah amazing here we go
this is now the current position thank
you cutie for helping me out there
bishop to e3 and bishop to e5 what do
you predict for this game that's been
wild roller coaster nico winning a piece
then myth winning it back a few moves later
tactics here and there what would be
your prediction i still see i still i hmm
i think nico's gonna take this in the end but
this is just a bit of a tricky situation right now
it's very tricky nico definitely has a lot more
experience than myth as we were pointing out
she played more games than most participants
combined she has been playing chess for years
already before it was even cool she's the og
actually she didn't know that i didn't know
that how long has she been playing like when
did she start chess did she have she ever said
i think her chess.com account
was created back in 2018 or wow
yeah she discovered chess before before it
was cool to play auto updating for us really
um bishop to a yeah bishop takes a7
i think we are up to date okay we're
good i hope it will keep yeah it keeps okay
moves finally we have reached a stage where
both players started spending a bit more time
the opening phase was an absolute bullet game
where both of them were blitzing out the moves
now method is down to five minutes nico's still
on seven and a half and now after capturing
the pawn on a7 she has a past pawn that a3 pawn
could be a potential queen but it's still
offer oh from promotion the evaluation
bar has jumped but i don't think this is
obvious what what's going on um the knight
is now on a square that is disconnecting
the black bishop from from that point
true ever since you mentioned that she had
that bishop of capture with the rooks hanging
i think she has seen it too now this is tough
for myth because suddenly he is down upon he
was up upon and he had the past two moves he
lost two pawns he's gotta move this rook now
where do you think he will move and there
aren't too many good fighters right above
right above well he forgets that that rook was
guarding the bishop on e5 and yeah takes it nico
excellent that was an interesting gesture there
by nico now myth could take the knight on c7 and
it's not background checkmate because of
the knight on d6 it could look like it's
checkmate and i wonder if if nico will try
to give checkmate you are nico's coach right
yes yeah one of her coaches the butter sisters
and me you know what happens if she loses hannah
it's your fault that's how it works that's what
happens if she loses it's all the coach's fault
every time well i hope she keeps going strong in
that case i hope she keeps going from bishop c5
i love it attacks the knight on d6 so she's now
again up a piece but knight takes c4 now the c7
knight is hanging under she trades there we go
that's a great movie i hope he does because if
he just moves the king the rook will be captured
for free so miss shouldn't give up more material
it takes he could have just
gone down and taken that night
correct you should have taken it before yes you
had that opportunity that was a missed opportunity
this should be now simple to convert if
it wasn't for that knight only being a
bit lost and bit apart from the
rest of the crew knight to d2
attacking the rook oh that's that's
a nice one because nico is pinning
the knight so it it cannot go wherever it
wants to the rook on b2 would be hanging
four minutes left for miss and seven minutes for
nico she's amazing at time yeah she's very fast
really a speedy player i think she's one of
the few who will not have an issue to adjust
to a tiebreaker when it comes to armageddon
or the blitz tiebreaker in the knockout stage
what was it like for you cutie the time control
you played the previous event that i think was
still 15 minutes the starting time but some of
the tiebreakers would be blitz or armageddon
did you find it difficult to adjust to rapid and
blitz no i liked it i liked i liked going fast i
think chess is a hard game because you have to
be insanely patient um oh we see a night fork
there there could be options with the knight um
at the same time niko is pushing the passport
i think that's a very good practical decision
in end games pawns become even more valuable a
lot more valuable than how they are actually
in the beginning of the game because you can
push them to the end of the board and that's what
she's doing she literally is just pushing it all
the way marching toward the background to promote
can me should be easy for her i don't think
um i mean he could just move his
rook over right and just get rid of
get rid of the pawn yes you are right then lose
his knight excellent yeah the thought process that
the right one that's exactly the right one because
you need to try to stop the pawn with the rook
but then the knight will be in trouble so that's
why this rook move by nico earlier pinning the
knight was a great decision and i think she knows
it that now her position oh miss is attacking both
the rook and the bishop but the rook on b2 was
unprotected now it's a full rook up for nico
oh poor myth um he fought very well but eventually
the experience of nico has decided i think some
of the most critical moments when everything was
hanging nico kept her cool and calculated better
and i am i'm gonna take uh everyone's mad at
me because i pointed out that fork from chat
but i am gonna listen to chat because i'm
here to represent chat so if i look stupid
it's because you guys look stupider and yeah i
just use stupider and i know that's not a word
but i want to look as dumb as you
guys okay and that's the goal here
it's embarrassing isn't it yeah
sorry to hear it okay so looking at
this nico still has seven whole minutes
i don't understand how she's so fast is anna
great perfect this is this is awesome um
anna looks lovely and i'm totally cut out for
this and you guys are enjoying yourselves and
we're having a good time and nico is gonna
take this w she's just gonna laddermate
any second now
myth is gonna fight it at this
point this is when everyone in
chat spams very toxically and they tell you
to resign but nico's got it that feels good
and myth myth is taking his loss well
it looks like he's gonna review the game
and we're just gonna take a
quick break before the next
match
though yeah
really careful of that team there we're gonna
be like blow to this team on pool though
let's get just bounce it
i think just bounce to the right
yeah yeah oh there's the floor
i think i bought my gun yeah
just go underneath it here
maybe i'll keep one down if
you want to get refreshed
uh
yes
from your box and then
we could bounce right and we could go we can
go above this we can go like but like we can
go i mean yeah we could land i don't know just
keep going i don't know i don't know though
okay i'll just follow you just do whatever
might be able to drop down like all
the way over here like with one bouncer
yeah i thought i was saying i could mean by that
though yeah you might get hard beamed actually
yeah yeah
yeah
uh
dead
they're gonna target me
and we are back hey cutie how's it going good
nothing has changed you saved chess from their
worst nightmare which was me representing them
alone so happy to have you here i'm gonna be
honest i watch you on chess tv all the time and
you're fantastic so i don't think it's so nice
there's no saving needed just all of the chat's
hair they're just pulling it out well hopefully
we don't got any mulders now i'm here i'm happy
to be here kitty you're doing an excellent job so
i think that they were in good hands regardless
oh good oh good well i'm excited to see this match
nico won the first match with a very cool
ladder mate after promoting a pawn and um
myth is in good spirits myth is a
very competitive person so i do think
an l hurts his soul but he'll never
admit that because he's an optimist
have liked to listen ends with him and just
hearing him cheer himself on but you know you
lose a game how do you turn it around like this
because it's no fun to you know struggle in any
match but how do you pump yourself up you know i
have a feeling that myth's best move here is just
to have fun because i don't think he's going to
win and so he might as well have fun taking the l
wow i have no faith okay well i mean some people
in the past during public gyms have taken a shot
some liquid courage right we've seen that
happen would you know anything about that
yes yes yes i'm a heavy drinker especially
before 5 p.m whoa i wasn't trying to call
anybody out here i'm just saying that some people
you know they just go within that actually could
improve their chess yeah i think maybe he could
try that i just think the great thing about myth
is he look at him he's still smiling yeah and he's
watching a chess video that's totally relevant
to what chess and fortnite what's
that board it's cool whatever it is
i don't want one probably really expensive this
should help him though i think it's a fortnight
themed chessboard he seems mesmerized yeah we'll
get him one of those he honestly just seems happy
yeah he's a good loser he he's just he's
happy even when he loses and i think that's
admirable because i cry when i lose actually
that's not yeah i won't play chess with ludwig
because i'm a bad loser but he's a bad winner
that surprises nobody yeah and well i guess we
do have the game i don't know if myth knows that
we have the game he's kind of just chillaxin
myth's board doesn't seem to be loading um
hopefully uh he refreshes soon his clock is
running and nico just seemed bored like hey
uh myth you want to get this one on the road oh
the game's cancelled we'll get it up and running
oh gosh i do wish i went into games like that
just chilled just chill just hanging back
i mean he seems as relaxed as he gets
and just to remind everybody that
and while we still have one more game here we
do have two more fun matches we've got ludwig
taking on code miko benji fishy against sardosh
so cutie any favorites in the other two matchups
i sh i can't speak on ludwig or code miko because
one of them will hate me if i choose any bias they
are both very important to me um and then benji
and sard what's his i'm so sorry ludwig just calls
him sardoush and i don't know his real name all
i can think of is sardoush sargosh sounds right
yes i am so he just goes around the house and
he's like can't wait to play sardine and i'm like
you've got to stop talking like that but sorry
dosh i think sardosh and benji are both really
really good but i'm personally afraid of fortnite
kids so okay i you know i don't know about how
scary they are but their chest has been great
those two and well we do have central control
by myth and nico moving quickly she typically does
so she plays really fast she does and i i wonder
she said before like sometimes she just feels
like she needs to move and that helps her chest
she's gained a lot of rating throughout this
pog champs she's up to 8.72 she started i think
in the 500s yeah when i saw how low she was i was
like wow nico sucks but then you know she's gotten
so good that now i'm afraid of her and i'm a
big nico stan okay i do the hey boomer dance
every morning and send it to her she doesn't reply
did you coach her as well because i know that you
have a coaching pedigree i did some coaching with
pokemane and then i retired i guess you know can't
uh climb any higher than that yeah okay one time
thing and while here nico plays b6 she's going
for another fianchetto and cutie do you see
this often in your games or is it pretty rare
uh this happens a lot um i never see it personally
i just lose my pieces but it does happen a lot
well nico is going for an aggressive plan with c5
striking the center and the engine bar just jumped
up here and it's because white can continue taking
space with a pawn push to e5 but it's very natural
that myth would take the pawn i think that's our
first instinct okay pawn has been taken by myth
and now that bar drops but it's so tricky because
when you're playing you obviously don't have the
bar and even while watching it may not be clear
but a large reason why is bishop on e3 normal
developing move this knight can come to g4 and
this bishop on g7 is the best piece on the board
i just think it's fascinating how far ahead
you can think because as you're talking i'm
barely catching up chess minds are insane can we
all agree um no i mean you know they're okay and
that also you're learning a lot i have watched
your streams i don't know if i should admit that
but i've watched your streams you know you
you're doing great you are learning and last
night for example i saw you playing you were
beating up on some peeps and you told a great
story i got to say that was a fantastic story the
one i peed in a cup that was the story yeah long
story chat sometimes you have to pee in a cup um
i think uh i got up to 900 rating and then i got
a lesson from donya and i fell back down to 800.
i don't know whose fault it is but it's not mine
you know donya is a good guy a great coach i think
he will take the blame as any good coach should
yeah i do think you are learning things and well
nico she's striking here with a5 she's pushing all
of her pieces forward and i don't think that myth
has a plan so actually when you when you look at
this position what are some ideas that you can
see here i mean if i were myth i would start
moving my knights his knights need to get out
there playing somehow am i crazy no no but he just
lost his bishop for a pawn there he oh
took there and the bishop was captured
so i think he's really sad for him i thought
it was free and ended up not being the case
oh wow sorry i have a rodent in my room
making some noise now the thing about
my cat is my cat is a big myth fan whenever i
want this is not a joke whenever i watch myth
nobody else i'll watch myth's stream and the
cat will come over and just sit and watch
so he's probably really upset that i'm rooting
for nico today but he loves myth and cats are
not always forgiving so i hope that you don't get
scratched too hard later no i think he'll be okay
well i hope so and for miss you know
he hopes that his position will be
okay because he dropped a piece for just
a pawn and the position still looks solid
for white but i like what nico's doing she's
ahead so she's trying to trade and if she can
just develop her pieces naturally try to go on
the b file because that's a pawn on b2 that can
be under attack it's hard to see how white on
the other hand means some attacking chances i
think yeah i think oh that was oh apparently not a
good move i thought that was a great move by miss
apparently not the b4 square not very well
defended but also nico has more time than she
started with nico's amazing with time it blows my
mind i mean she's just too fast and she honestly
maybe there should be a bullet tournament
with all you getting one minute on the clock
i think she could win it i'm curious if she's ever
tried bull i'd love to see her her bullet games
um judging by how she plays in during this
podcast i think she'd be pretty good she's
playing well she's playing fast confidently and
now she's up a piece and myth is trying to figure
out what to do how to push forward he looks so
concentrated he's a gamer he's a gamer by nature
i think myth should work on his
intimidation tactics he looks too nice
so what would he have to do i think he should um
you know i think he should call nico some names
i think he should tweet at her and he should be
like bye boomer i think that's what he should do
and maybe it'll mess her up and she'll lose
is it that simple buy boomer and then well i've
tried doing stuff like that it's never worked
but maybe for her maybe for her and if mitt did
turn on that like mean streak i don't even know
if it's possible like i feel like no one would
believe it so no yeah no one would believe it i
did have a lesson with anna where i taught anna um
how to talk [ __ ] and it was hilarious um sweet
anna being mean to chess players is not something
you've seen often but it was awesome it was great
uh well i think we could all learn a thing or two
from not just about being mean to other people but
uh you know in many other regards including chess
you are making progress here so black is still up
a piece this king on g1 is in trouble how do
you think that black should continue this game
i think um i think that bishop needs to get out
of there it's all tucked in that's all i think
about again i'm here to represent the normal
people in chat not the brilliant people in chat
but all i can think about is normal no you're not
normal wow that hurts your brain is massive okay
and it's not fair to the rest of us that
are subpar at everything thought we're
getting along real well but not normal so i'm
still angry about it oh my gosh oh oh okay
so using your idea though to get the bishop out
but could drop in 94. yeah i think we're just
going to lose that knight well that's just a trade
i suppose correct well a pawn was taken and oh the
engine did not like that move so the big issue and
she just took a knight on c3 is that this king has
been out in the open so actually just a move ago
queen out to b6 check puts this king in a world of
hurt but knight 63 you can't complain about that
as she took a piece and she still is up material
hey nice to be staring at the queen right now
true where would you move that queen i mean
i would just i would just trade if i was oh he
does it he goes queen c8 so she's trying to trade
you're up uh a bishop and a pawn so that makes
sense just to liquidate into a simpler position
to win i think we missed the big storyline is
that niko's under 10 minutes moving too slowly
yeah nico's really got to work on her time i
thought she was doing well i take it all back
yeah i think we're all disappointed in
her for the slow pace that she's moving at
what in what world does myth come back um i
don't know you tell me you've played this term
before how dare you how dare you turn that
back on me i was just trying to scare you
ask a fantastic commentator her thoughts on how a
player can mount a comeback that's all i think he
myth could pay someone to get the power
turned off at nico's house i think and then oh
oh no he goes no no i forgot texas
i'm so sorry um i i just think i think
nico decides to blunder a queen that's what
you always hope for let's just blend our queen
and he can come back okay the problem with
that though is that she put a rook on d.a
so she's doing the great things just trying to
trade off the pieces and a certain point white
doesn't have much remaining so there can't even
be some surprise tactics or like hey you won't
see that i'm hitting your queen because the only
pieces you have remaining hmm so he needs to he
needs to get that knight out there and try to do
something with that right that's the only thing
yeah unfortunately it's uh pretty
stuck in place it is really stuck
i hear a cat he's mad because miss is losing i
told you he is he doesn't want to hang out in here
anymore i just we'll see he'll come back i hope so
and well i think it's now time for nico to go on
the offensive because this king is open you are up
a bishop in a pawn oh okay okay i clearly have to
let him out i'm so sorry about him no you're all
good you're all good the cat's meow strikes again
and honestly this show just got way worse now i'm
solo this hurts to watch for everybody i'm sorry
cutie we'll be right back i hope i don't
want to be here too oh there she is
really fast you saved me i stream in a closet so
you saved me why what happened i mean oh wow look
we got some rooks traded we did but i was alone
and that was unacceptable oh okay yeah great hmm
moving maybe there's a world where i
like to live in um oh he's in check yeah
yeah check here and you gotta go somewhere so
king f2 the problem is the king will never find
actual safety the knight can just drop back and
the queen will infiltrate so i think knight d4
makes sense and then bring the
queen in to f3 and this king is in
big big big trouble oh he's
going to attack attack the knight
so you think nico's gonna move her knight what
are the chances she doesn't move the knight and
she loses it none zero nico's a queen she knows
this okay i mean you know her better than i do and
you're her big supporter she brought a queen in
speaking of queen and she defended her night there
that's that's my girl i knew it we
didn't have any problems with that
yeah so you're proving your worth as a chess
commentator right now yeah i can predict
so what's next what's up now well
unfortunately i think myth's gonna get mated
okay right am i missing something no it seems
like you're you're correct but how would black
go about delivering that checkmate this feels
like an awful chess lesson hess i know you know
okay don't i know you know i'm genuine i
was asking a question oh this was a good
move love that oh never mind okay hmm myth is so
focused i've never seen myth this focus though
yeah he's locked in right now and he's trying
to figure out how can he save this game
and hovering on that queen back to
the night going from peace to peace
this is just such a sad situation oh
this is interesting so maybe bringing
this down taking the night trading
queens i think that's a smart move
yeah he that he's not interested in
i think you saw his knight is under
attack now he's hopping around
he's really concentrated yeah this is safe though
okay so the queen's under attack so
nico has to see and she does that
her queen's enough to actually give
the check giving up her night to win
myths night so it's a fair trade night for night
and with the extra material it seems like nico is
you know pushing well on her path to victory for
as far as nico is ahead i think myth is holding on
yeah and you know i mean she still needs to
win the game right and her bishop is pinned
it's the queen is very active for white so
he needs to keep up the pressure and for
nico she needs to figure out a way to get that
bishop involved imagine this just falls on time
okay she doesn't get the mate and myth just
runs out of time that would be so sad for
me why would it be sad for you it's just so
it's not satisfying oh i can't be the only
one that thinks that you need to check me is
what you're saying yeah yeah i agree i agree
and myth has three plus minutes so
he does have time to make his moves
and he doesn't have that many pieces remaining
so i guess at a certain point he can shuffle
and he needs to be careful because now this
pawn is under attack in addition to the check
he's been checked again yeah interesting
uh-huh and he moves king up so that was really
smart because if this pawn had been captured
uh let's say you make this move and the pawn
is captured you also lose your queen at the
end of the line so he was smart to make the
move that he did king up and comes the queen
so is nico just gonna keep pinning trying to
get that queen is that i think that's what
she's gonna try to do yeah she gave the check she
can just trade queens and then win the end game
bring her king up and then moving her pawns
in a in a world where how
difficult is just the bishop
a bishop king check is that something that nico
is familiar with so there are situations where
the bishop will not be enough so like we trade
all the pawns off and there's no only bishop
and king versus king that's a draw so you
need to be able to keep your extra material
and there's some more nuanced things here if
black only has this bishop and this pawn on h7
this actually is a draw of white just puts
the king in the corner but unfortunately
well she could have taken the pawn f4 she's
trading more this could be a tricky situation
this just comes to as soon as she gets a pawn
promoted that's gg that would be gigi exactly
and she needs to keep her f pawns and she just
bring her king up to the party that's the thing
it's an end game you want your king under the
arrow backwards you want your king out up and
going and so she's going this way her king is
marching in and that's the last piece needed
and she still has eight minutes on the
clock yeah amazing she's too fast too strong
she is our queen i've said it i've said
it so now yes she's yours she's yours too
we live in this state you and i the state of
chess.com and we decide who our queen is and
it is nico today okay and by we decide
you mean i decide okay god i just want
to make sure we didn't even say in that
yes yes absolutely we're on the same page
chad has decided that you are
their queen though it seems
oh i'm not deserving of such an honor i voted
for nico chad voted for hess i guess hess will
wear the crown today he has a little more votes
i suppose oh well i guess we have to do a poll to
see what they really think right it's the only way
through true true run the numbers yeah we're data
people here and it's running this pawn is running
queen is happening i think nico has us under
control the only question i have is will she have
more than 10 minutes when the game ends i hope so
i'll be interested to see where did how many
matches is niko won this will be her first
yes of your first match win that'll
awesome awesome awesome awesome but
be careful not to sail mate okay the
king has one move so it wasn't stalemate
and now the king has some space but that was
actually pretty close she's making a third queen
i hope so she's playing with her food
but be careful not to stalemate when you
have too many queens you could accidentally
allow your opponent to get a stalemate
just making no mercy no mercy me nico
i almost said mikko uh oh freudian slip
wow no one tell mika i'm thinking about her
it's okay she might shoot off into space
yeah mars oh one is gone that was interesting
he said what there it is oh there it is there's
the finale two nothing for nico and myth was just
absolutely startled by the queen can i take that
he probably shouldn't have taken it would have
given him better stalemate chances yeah that's a
good point oh gosh well 2-0 score cutie was fun
and i guess we gotta go into a break so we
can bring the players on for an interview
can't wait you sound stoked i love talking to
them that's my favorite part okay well then
we might as well run there quickly
and leave uh ludwig for all the watch
like um like a nitro cold brew street cream and
i was like that's like 150 calories too many
i was like i'm just gonna get this black coffee
with a bit oh jesus christ i'm gonna test out
okay chess.com i'm telling a story about starbucks
i'll catch you up basically when i go to starbucks
i like to get a drink without too many calories
because if you have liquid calories you're just
it's the easiest way to gain weight and i
am so close to 200 pounds i'm at 199 pounds
if i if i hit 200 this game over i quit streaming
all right which like 80 ubereats drivers who hate
my stream are going to [ __ ] bring me free food
but seriously i don't want to hit 200 it's a scary
number so when i go to starbucks i like to just
get like a black coffee with a little bit of milk
that's it that's all i get it's a simple order and
every time i get it all i say is hey can i get a
venti iced coffee with some milk two percent milk
and they're like yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
go around get it and it's like it's like
it's weird to describe but it's like it's
like a good drink i'm like damn i i kind
of [ __ ] with this drink you know and
and i'm like i go to these other coffee places the
fancier ones in la and i order the same thing and
it always tastes worse and i'm like huh i don't
know i just i really like the milk they use cause
the sweetness from the milk brings it out and one
time i'm with my roommate nick who's like a coffee
savant he's like a five head in coffee worked at
a barista place for like four years and i'm like
yeah man dude you should try this coffee like the
sweetness from the milk makes it delicious and he
tries it and he like recoils he's like oh he's
like that's so sweet i'm like yeah it's the milk
and he looks at me like the biggest [ __ ] idiot
to land on planet earth and he's like you think
that's the milk i'm like yeah that's the milk
yeah because i just order yeah i order a venti
iced coffee with a bit of milk and the
milk has a bit of sugar if you don't know
he might not know this you know nick you
know milk a little there's a little milk
it has a little sugar when it comes from the
cow teat and so he looks at me and he's like
starbucks automatically puts a pump of sugar syrup
in every single drink if you don't ask for it
and so i tested this the next time i asked for
an iced coffee with milk and a pump of syrup
right because that's what i like i go around
i pick it up the drink is even [ __ ] sweeter
which i don't understand so there's like two
drinks you can get in iced coffee with milk
and sugar and if you ask for that you got
an iced coffee with milk in too much sugar
or you ask for an iced coffee with milk and then
you get an iced coffee with milk and sugar the
perfect amount but you can't say sugar because if
you say sugar they give you too much sugar so you
have to not say sugar to get a pump of sugar but
if you say sugar you get too many pumps of sugar
and now every time i go through the drive-through
i ask for an iced coffee with milk but sometimes
then they don't put the sugar in anyways i'm
having a very frustrating experience going through
the starbucks drive-throughs trying to get a
simple drink because i don't know how to ask
for it because if i ask for sugar it's too much
i got partner on twitch this morning i'm so happy
thank you for being an inspiration to me
maybe someday i can be a content god like you
hey man just give me 50 of all your revenue and
then we'll work together all right we'll go for
the uh the rice gum deal the rice come deal of
a lifetime appreciate the fiber though uh anyway
and we're back joined by the players nico first
off congrats how does it feel to score your first
dub um it feels good um i really was feeling a
little down because i was like i really did lose
to little boy benji and then a french dude named
shasar dosh so i was like i need to get some kind
of win and luckily myth was like hey i'm gonna
let nico win and i was like nice a silver platter
on a silver platter here yeah well cutie's cat
was rooting for you miss he is my cat oh my gosh
really would you say hi to my son please he's
a big fan of this is a big fan of you i might
have i might i lost the battle but i won the war
because cutie's cat loved me he loves your stream
completely fine he's the biggest myth simp in
the world let's go i have one finally but i'm
the biggest nico simp so nice split household
crazy so she did great today yeah i mean nico
so you were playing really quickly did you
just we're feeling it today i mean what was
your mindset going in uh taking on myth in this
matchup i mean i wasn't i wasn't uh far from myths
elo reading like three weeks ago and then i just
got back into like grinding chess and i feel like
i've already been playing for like over a year so
i kind of already knew what the mindset is at that
elo so i feel like i had like an advantage there
um and and yeah so so i was i kind of already was
in myth shoes not too long ago so i feel like i
already had like an advantage in that sense she
said that elo how do you feel about that myth
that evo dude i feel like i it wasn't even a
battle today then dude i step into nico's
world that's what happened today exactly
dude is anybody here watching jutsu kaizen she
just pulled you know she pulled out her realm
and engulfed me in it that's what happened
today i didn't know what i was getting into
he's right that i knew the mental space of
that elo and i came into assault and uh and
take advantage of it oh yeah but i felt it i mean
it's true i mean it's a really good fight though
yeah and cutie was saying that if you trash
talks you think maybe it could help your chest
i think you should have you know tweet it out
talk some [ __ ] to nico tell her how bad a
video game she is and she would have not even
shown up today at the same mental that's true
i was hoping for [ __ ] talk man i'm positive
that would have cracked her next time next time
yep indeed and well and i guess the next match you
guys both that will be in the consolation bracket
how do you see your chances are you thinking
that far ahead or just uh happy to have this
match under your belt and what's your mindset like
i mean i i'm really i'm really ready to take uh
some more lessons uh with anna and then the other
anna kramling she plays also chess so i'm really
looking forward to that i wasn't able to take any
lessons this week because of the dallas storm so i
everything was out power was out everywhere
just flew out to california so i did haven't
had time to take lessons but hopefully i could
it could prepare me for the um for that bracket
admit you've been working with maurice right
uh yeah we've i've had two sessions uh with
maurice so far yeah a little bit you're gonna
get ready for that consolation bracket it should
you know you're gonna avoid these sardoshes and
the benji fishes of the world so you feeling good
about some of your chances there yeah yeah i hope
i think i definitely have some more work to do
overall but uh i definitely i'm excited i'm
excited to go up against my my consolation brother
constellation bracket is
the fun bracket anyway okay
the winner's bracket they try
too hard they're so sweaty
you don't you don't want to hang out those people
anyway you know what you're right cutie yeah
bunch of bullies i lost the consolation bracket
when i was in it so i can't oh no you're fine
listen i mean my fate uh listen i'll
be joining you in the lost consolation
bracket club so all right maybe they'll
invite you back next time because then
you know underdog story another
shot that's what you shoot for
well we appreciate you both coming on it's a
great match we enjoyed it and best of luck in
the consolation match and keep up the trash talk
i mean i hope it gets better for you myth and
for nico congrats on the win thank you thank you
and gg smith it was great it is nico thanks for
slaying me out bye thanks guys oh that was awesome
and well cutie you know your advice to myth was to
get the trash talk going i try to spur them on a
little bit here but next we have ludwig against
codemico any thoughts cutie any thoughts anything
no i this is i'm sure they will handle trash talk
um by themselves i don't think i'll
need to do any of that and i don't think
i should make any comments on how i want the match
to go today i i don't think i should make any
verbal comments about that okay so this is your
version of just pleading the fifth you're going
to stay sun i'm not going to say anything i just
you know they're both good friends of mine and i
just hope for the best here so does code miko have
friends because like ai like how does that work
not to call you out or anything you want to
be code miko's friend because you never know
what she can do that's she's terrifying so
friendship out of fear that's a great friendship
yeah yeah i did have a lesson with code miko and
i taught her the direction of the knights and it
was very exciting for the two of us i'm glad you
had that moment well we will have a lot of waiting
on komiko next fall by benji fishy and sardosh
but i would like to take a moment here to thank
guayaqui for supporting product champs this
year as guayaquil celebrates 25 years of
regenerative yerba mate they're sharing cases
to celebrate spam the guayaki emote in chat for
your chance to win and we'll be back after
the break to start the next match of the
day
q anon is not guys you need to get over
the dwight true thing you actually sound
like you not supporters when you talk about
dwight schrute throwing every five seconds
it is just not factual dwight shirt did not throw
i'm on chess.com okay can i ask a question
chess.com why are we even streaming this is
it not against terms of service to stream a
[ __ ] massacre code miko is gonna get her
[ __ ] pushed in this is she's gonna quit the
game of chess okay this it's not gonna be look
i've heard her bots better than her i made it
in eight the other day what is that move okay
let's get a little it's a little freaky maybe
surely he takes no okay surely he takes
no okay surely he takes okay uh-huh
let's uh let's do maybe one
of wait surely she takes
why why why would that be the move even a six what
is wrong with you guys it's you did her so dirty
okay
okay all right
i was nervous i was nervous
oh my god oh no i'm gonna lose
weight
why why why i don't get it okay
uh let's do let's do a classy
bishop out attacking the queen protected
protected was my last word i worked at starbucks
for five years yeah you have to say the exact
number of pumps you want each size comes
with a set number of pumps and it's always
no [ __ ] starbucks so chat they should
tell you they put sugar in their drinks
they should tell you they put sugar in their
drinks people in america believe in q and on
they're not smart enough to recognize their
sugar and drinks and they're just having
too many calories it should be against
the law how does this game end like this
i don't even know how to find a checkmate here
here
i don't know how to mate i might
not be able to win this game
if i lose the code mikko's bot i'm
going to feel real bad about myself
check check oh my god okay all right i don't
even know what i'm doing but that worked out
what does your shirt say i don't want to show
i don't want to show you
guys cutie made me wear it
i'm not going to show you the shirt cutie
made me wear it i don't want to wear it
fine
it's stupid it's stupid i hate it i hate
i didn't want to wear it today she made
me wear it it's i but it's because i didn't
have any clothes clean it's it's a dumb shirt
i like the color
it's a pretty color
all right chat let's do a bet
not a poll on whether i be code miko
a prediction over under 20 moves
we'll do 20.5 moves
i don't think code miko
will win but i think she could easily go over
i think under 20 is really hard to find a mate
but i think it's a better prediction it's
closer to 50 50 rather than just doing a 95 pull
this is only the beginning
hey me again luscious larry leather browns sweaty
heavy pocky leathery wait don't kiss him i'm your
son i'm here from the future if you kiss him i
won't exist so please hey i love your belt is that
what you wear in the future rad totally what my
grip 6 belt i know right i love this no flailing
flaps bulging buckles they're hideous holes and
with a lifetime guarantee you really can't go
mother
and pog jam 3 presented by grip 6 grip 6
belts are unlike any belt you've ever had
they're comfortable and don't pinch your gut
with a lifetime warranty it will be the last
belt you ever buy check them out at go.chest.com
grip6 and cutie we have a great lineup of players
you know them better than i do a lot of way
code miko coming up next but any players
just want to talk about we have some time yeah
let's let's leak all of their secrets actually
um pokemane something about her she actually
loves putting peanut butter between her toes
and um and walking on the beach it's her favorite
thing that's a serious serious thing ludwig has
worn the same dirty sweatpants for the past
four days um that he spilled hot sauce on and
he won't change them well the most
important question is what kind of hot sauce
i don't know but that one's actually true the
other one is not but i can leak more secrets if
you would like um yeah i mean i'm happy to hear
them but i guess i'm also happy to talk about how
uh there's a lot of money and awareness being
raised throughout the pog champs here you know
we are here lots of community outreach chess.com
is willing to match up to 100 000 of the viewing
committee's donations during the event and they'll
be giving to the participants preferred non-profit
organizations in the splits you see in front
of you and the players they've all chosen their
organizations well i shouldn't say all because i
still see two tbas tbas means to the bank account
that's what that means did you just come up
with that or i stole it from chat chat is funny
sometimes when they try hard okay gotcha well
i i found it funny i thought it was you so now
you're too honest i would have given you full
credit oh shoot next time next time it's okay
because i think i think sardosh and xqc will
they'll choose a charity at some point we think
there's a lot of pressure now
now would be weird if they didn't
yeah although i thought usa when you live
with sardosh that he might be the champion
and he has a tough matchup today but
he's looked great his reigns almost 1400
i i have a big i think it's going to be benji i
think benji's going to win that match later today
why is that is it because nico called him
little benji boy child little benji boy he
is the champion in all of us he represents all of
us if we were good at video games as a child and
none of us were and that's why we're unsuccessful
and poor right chad well benji's been putting a
lot of hard work in i've seen him streaming with
grandmaster young loving hammer uh taking lessons
he's clearly improving and sardoche as well with
nemo i believe one of the world's best players
maxine russell the grav is giving him lessons the
french community is coming strong for sardoche
oh i guess it's just it that'll be a fun game to
watch and totally understand what is going on um i
think this next match with ludwig and mikko though
will just be an absolute i'm going to feel bad
for mikko i have to say it i don't have that much
faith in ludwig i just have that little faith in
i i
requires a certain amount of attention span that i
thought i didn't have but miko really doesn't have
so the bot doesn't have an attention
span that's worrisome for all of yeah
you know yeah but she will look cute doing it and
i know that and sometimes that's half the battle
and well what about ludwig then i don't know if
he's changed his pants if he has changed his pants
then maybe there's hope but otherwise we
don't know about that look keep doing it
yeah well until that moment i guess uh your
code miko stan that makes sense and we do also
have great matchups ahead tomorrow for those
of you who will be back it's the weekend you
got nothing better let's be honest true pokemon
taking on rubius daniel legrando taking an xqc
those are the group b match ups and then
in group c we have rain wilson versus logic
and those two have both been very impressive
as they've won their first two matches
that is the craziest thing how did we get
logic and rain wilson in the same room
um they were asked and they liked chess tell
me tell me how much money chess.com had to
switch you tell tell me tell me i keep doing
stuff for free for chess.com you leak it you
leak it now anybody who's listening to chess.com
streams they know that danny doesn't pay me so
oh my gosh this is this is insane we you know
what let's let's revolt let's say nothing let's
say nothing so you want to sit here in silence
yeah until they pay us that's right yeah now what
you're still talking i feel like you made it
awkward i was ready to sit in silence but then
you started talking again and all right guys fine
you don't need to pay us but you should donate to
charity today that's true because all donations
go to charity right and chess.com matching up to
a hundred thousand dollars in donations going to
charity it's certainly a good cause and well cutie
i don't know how else to preview this
matchup between ludwig and code miko
i think we're all pretty pumped for
it so why don't we take a short break
and then when we return we'll be ready
for the game to begin i'm excited
can you see the sun is
are we starting soon
komiko i'm gonna go e4 f3 with my
knight d4 letting you know right now
and if you go black i'm mirroring
everything you do for 10 moves
free move no the only thing i steal from
charlie is the rest of his content coming soon
i changed my pants i took a shower today
my hair is like chill i worked out
wait chess.com is watching right now still
hi sweetie how's it going um i hope
you cheer me on in my match i love you
and as per usual cutie i didn't listen to
a word that led how to say how is he saying
um how's he standing well typically cocky
overconfident and full of [ __ ] that's
usually how he's sounding but i don't know how
he's sounding today i haven't listened either
so gosh it gotcha expectations are high
clearly yes yes yes okay um yeah that's fair
and i wonder how code miko's feeling because after
the match against charlie charlie was saying hey
you can crush lori that bot nah that's better
than he is and there's a little bit of friendly
rivalry between moist critical and ludwig and of
course they're meeting in their final match of
the group stage i'm nervous about that because
if if ludwig wins or i mean if ludwig loses
he's going to be a menace to deal with and if
he wins he's going to be a menace to deal with
like either way so if you think about
there's nothing to be nervous about
because it's the same result yeah so i just just
i'm just going to need to go somewhere that day
regardless i just don't want to hang out with him
got it well i heard there's a good ice cream place
that's in uh disneyland that you might think about
going to yeah yeah salt and straws and anyone's
ever heard of it it is so busy all the time and
i recommend them and you want to wait eight hours
yeah sounds fair and we do have a pretty breaking
announcement which is exciting that in addition to
three matches we highlighted tomorrow we will also
see pokeman take on xqc so lots of chess tomorrow
four matches it's going to be a really exciting
day i'm excited i love watching pokey play i love
watching pokey do anything sounds like you're a
fan i'm a big pokey fan i've been a big pokey fan
got it and you were her first chess coach i was
her first chess coach i got that lesson by telling
her that i could pencil her in after my lesson
after i gave a lesson to caru and a gatomater i
said maybe i can squeeze you in let me know if
you have time yourself and she said wow i would
love if you could make some time for me and i said
of course and i cleared my schedule just for her
you're just such a generous soul and it got
really awkward when she would ask me questions
like what should i do now oh they already started
they jumped in yeah but she could have used your
advice before this situation happened because
in the petrov after e4 the knight hits the pawn
taking it you should not take back you need to
kick the knight first before you take this pawn
because of this exact sequence if
the knight moves out of the way
then white will have a discovery so if the
knight goes to f6 this knight moves it's check
on the king and knight c6 picks up the queen
and you can't block that would be a loss there
uh-oh nico looks slightly confused and miko's
yelling oh gosh oh my god feeling a sword
and
i don't say is mikko okay mikko miko's
dealing with this on an existential level
and well i was thinking
ludwig almost looks frozen he's thinking so
hard right now interesting movement if love
is frozen you know something is wrong
because usually a very talkative lad
and look at this logic played pawn to d3
and that's a knight so miko brings the
bishop out to defend the square but ludwig
takes a night for the cost of just a pawn
i don't think mikko is at the point where she
understands point values we talked about it
and she kind of hit me with the blah
blah blah blah blah which i understand
um i feel like that's the first thing a bot should
know how to do is quick accounting that isn't what
we use calculators and everything for yeah she's
a unique unique bot got it and well ludwig's
bopping his head so i think he feels pretty good
there's a check made in one threat on the f7 pawn
you think mika will not see this no no no she
will probably bring out a knight or a pawn i don't
think she will see the checkmate and sometimes we
forget that it's not just the palm center tactics
if you push the pawn thinking it's under attack
the queen still goes to that very square that's
an easy thing to make a mistake about because
you think the queen's capturing the pawn but no
it's trying to go there with checkmate that's the
bigger thing i mean she's oh yeah oh and um
it's game one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh-huh
yeah yeah yeah it's okay it happens it's okay
the issue is is right now i guarantee mikko's
like how is that check and she's looking
for it and i'm listening to love's music
hey hey still better than excuse me bad
winner bad winner ludwig is bad winner
he does this even when we're in
the living room this is not like
this is not new yeah i mean ludwig is the far more
experienced player and by the way i just want to
give a shout out to i'm gumby gambit for a hundred
dollar donation that's very generous and well a
lot of it kind of looks like gumby out there and
i know that there's a gumby costume too right
he does have a gumby costume ludwig has a gumby
costume he bought it and then followed it up with
gumby is attractive or something
like that and i was very confused
because i've never thought that myself
so maybe that donation was from ludwig
but has if you've ever had a crush on a
cartoon character as a child who was no
you just hit me with a no you don't think
lola bunny was hot like in space jam yeah
i mean no but i guess for some people wow what
about jessica rabbit also gonna have to pass
simba i mean you know we're
doing all right now yeah but
yeah you learn a lot about people you ask them
if they like if they're more of a simba or kovu
a mufasa or a scar you know so what's
your mind mufasa scar well which one are
you attracted to that's the question i thought
you were calling me one or the other no got it
um neither can i can i go with that or do i have
to choose one you have to choose oh well then scar
perfect yeah right that's wow this is a lot
now we've learned a lot this is very exciting
for you and for your father who's watching
this um yeah you know he's a fan of yours
it's not necessarily mine but uh yeah that
i forgot about that that makes us a little
more awkward well we were hoping to do this um
but besides gumby being attractive mikko seems
to be handling this loss well and saying that
she doesn't even like chess wow that's a that's
a familiar feeling for all chess yeah that's
how you know that mikko is a true chess player
i think i think it's a fair reaction
anybody who spends time on a game
and wants to do better when you lose
it sometimes you just say you hate it
and it's fair yeah it hurts because you care and
well komiko has been in tears in previous matchups
but we'll see how coco's feeling we're going to
take a break and when we return we'll be back
for the second part of this match of
production three broad presented by group six
look guys we're learning chess
we're learning chess everybody
huh
oh
oh i see
um are we playing the next game
take chess.com hey you can turn off emote only
now we only do it more only when the chess is
when we're playing a game does that make sense
mods
when we're when we're playing the game we do emote
only when we're not playing the game we don't know
freedom hi hey everybody let technician play
no it is i oh man hey thank you so much knight
source for gifting 5k1 stuff okay how about
this i will play slower i'll play slower and
uh i'll try to use i'll try to think i'll
try to think before i make moves how's that
yeah i'll try to use my brain
thank you so much for giving
five to one sausage community
i'll make some announcements while we wait guys so
everybody if you have not already subscribe to my
youtube channel for we are going to and we return
getting ready for the second game of the match
between ludwig and code miko and just want to give
a quick chest pointer out here so in the opening
after e4 e5 knight f3 this pawn is under attack
so typically black brings the knight out to c6
because the knight on c6 protects the pawn e5
instead komiko plays what's known as the petrol
defense it's a perfectly reasonable move it's
played by some of the best players in the world
but after knight takes e5 you need to know that
taking on e4 is not good because of exactly what
lottery did of lining up the queen against the
enemy king so d6 is necessary that when the knight
retreats and the knight captures on e4 after queen
e2 black can interpose the queen and that way
you save the material so just a little quick
chest opening run through and thank you thank
you for explaining that i was gonna do it but i'm
happy you did it ludwig's probably singing a song
yeah well i wanted to take it off your plate he
does i told you bad winner he is a bad winner
yeah he destroys her in what was that eight
moves six moves his eight moves eight moves
destroys her in eight moves and then goes and
celebrates bonk cloud or riot look look look
look look look very simply very simply i'm trying
to take this tournament seriously and uh you know
i also can't believe he's wearing that shirt for
the record i did not think i'm better than michael
that shirt it's a stupid shirt so i'll take
even the games where i'm so assured to win
as seriously as i can and put them in the [
__ ] dirt he said you forced him to wear it
i've been asking him to change his pants for
the last three days i can't make him do anything
that's not that's crazy it's that work from home
loungewear yeah he can just chill in the same
sweatpants for oh my gosh oh gosh my freaking
awesome girlfriend i can't read all the fine
print but that's she's a bit crazy she has anger
issues but she's a perfect mixture of sweetheart
and warrior i love her so much she's my life
flirt with me and you'll be dead or something
like that have you put that to memory or did you
just read that very quickly okay i made the shirt
i wrote it oh okay got it got it i'm just kidding
it's from amazon i just read it really quickly
wow i couldn't even i could barely see it i just
saw the really large print and that's about it
all right they're off yeah they'll see lot of
wood knight in c6 to protect the pawn e5 so
now we'll see if kodmiko goes for bishop c4 the
italian game and yes she does staring at the pawn
on f7 potentially for attack but i think ludwig
his experience here he knows how to handle this
miko said she was going to use her brain this
game is what she learned from the last game
she said i'm going to use my brain this game
the weird thing to hear from a bot brain bot
really don't go hand together so well but i
think it's working this new tactic is working
and let's seems hyped he seems really
into this position but he hasn't moved
what does his mud face say to you
telling a story he's telling a story
you know about the fried liver or something like
it's so fun and you make money for charity and you
play like it'll take like an hour of your time and
that's how they pitch it because they just want
big streamers and youtubers to come on he's just
playing they said to mr beast yo you're gonna come
with this tournament you're probably gonna get [
__ ] rolled by people unless you put in like 50
hours a week no they're like bro hour and a half
tops all right it's so a lot of people come on and
they get [ __ ] rolled and they don't realize that
everyone might be taking this tournament seriously
uh because uh they weren't so upfront about that
because at the end of the day chess.com's motive
is to get more attention to chess and their
website which is done by getting big people
on but big people don't always have the time
but they're big for a reason it's because they
put time another thing please play the channel
don't be too hard on contestants who aren't able
to put as much time as like tofu in the chess it
is not a flaw or a mistake it is just because they
don't really know what they're signing up for uh
and you know it can make for funny matches but i
just i worry sometimes about the competitors who
have signed up uh because you know this seems like
a fun thing to do and and then they get [ __ ]
destroyed for not putting in 20 hours a week into
a game that they didn't think they had to that
they didn't think they might have had to um they
thought they'd just do a few fun coaching lessons
or whatever anyway um what the hell is even that
see that's what i think i think pogchamp should be
just fun and it's not our fault that ludwig
is so sweaty and he tries so hard okay
some of us yes he plays chess every single night
on an alt account he has an alt chess account
not this ludwig ogren one he literally has an
alt check don't spill his secrets i'm going
to because mikko just wants to have fun but why
can't you have fun and try hard at the same time
no absolutely not okay i'm just trying to you
know stick out for lud skywalker over here no
no no i just think you know some of us some
of us we just want to have fun we just want
to have a good time myth myth is one of them you
know maybe i'm just defending being bad whoa whoa
come on don't don't be so hard on yourself you
approved so much during part two well yeah well
i didn't get invited back to pog3 so it wasn't my
decision i was super rude of you me what did i do
you didn't ask me no we didn't have a conversation
about this they told me i didn't have 500 000 subs
on youtube so they wouldn't invite me back oh
well i don't even have a youtube page so then
they told me they'd invite me to commentary so i
wouldn't call them sexist again and i said okay
okay well now you're here won't call you sexist
twitch i mean chess i'll still call twitch sexist
my bad oh gosh and well ludwig looking more
serious he's biting his nails so he's focused
he put his knight on g4 going for an attack
but i think he knows better than the take on f2
a lot of people would be tempted into that because
after knight takes f2 it looks like you're hurting
the white king but in this trade white gets two
minor pieces for rook and a pawn and the king
isn't actually that unsafe it can quickly drop
back and buy donya taught me that actually only
like three weeks ago and so i always i always let
them do it and i always it's my favorite trick
it's a good one to keep in mind and well ludwig
does not take on f2 instead of his knight d4
and he is trying to remove this knight from f3
so that his queen can go out to h4 and cause some
problems for him i see yeah he is tricky that's
definitely what he's doing you spend a lot of time
with ludwig hess doesn't want you guys
to know but they spend a lot of time
off stream together it's getting a little weird
i mean i don't know what's weird about you're
making it weird do you want to talk about your
relationship my relationship with ludwig you
mean that we just casually play chess sometimes
and hang out every day uh it's not every day
wow in fact was it today no because i was going to
do some chest him before his match but here i am
hanging out with you i chose you over him
how does that feel you're still he's still
right here no but he's not really here you know
you're you're the one letting him get between
this uh fun time all right well uh he hasn't or
the knight did wait so he's still blocked off
wait he blocked himself off with that knight
right yeah because code miko put the pawn to
attack the knight and ludwig just retreated the
knight and something that was really smart that
happened here is that black is ready to play
pawn c6 because that bishop while it looks
strong with the pawns protecting it it actually
doesn't have any scores to go to so c6 oh wow
about to happen and ludwig's about to trap that
bishop well he needs to take care of his king
first and they protected the f7 pawn with the
castle great that bishop is locked in there
yes and i think that komiko might have to
take on f7 at some point because that bishop
is stuck and let me actually miss the tactic so
this knight is not defended by anything if the
knight on f6 were to hop out the way this queen
could go ahead and win it so even a move ago
knight takes bishop after the capture
is happens on the d5 square this knight
can be taken back oh wow you missed something
oh he's embarrassing um he's wearing the same
set of sweatpants for the third for the past
three days that have his gross stain on them
oh so d3 played trying to get the bishop love
it quickly plays c6 and kodmiko has nothing
better to do than take on f7 that one if i if
i move this here this is the most concentrated
i've ever heard okay that's fine you know
what that's fine i'm gonna i'm gonna go for um
i'm just going to
keep developing like this
and yeah i understand that what happened he just
took my bishop right so then maybe i'll take hmm
took my bishop that's okay that's okay it's
fine she's not gonna take one of those pawns
maybe i can go she should but she's trying
to figure out a way to get active here
i'll just take this there
she goes it's fine well done
it's very pensive she's really thinking hard
here she's really thinking about her moves here i
this is she's down a minute on ludwig
and he's going fast he's having no mercy
as soon as you see that she just curses out
of nowhere and well we saw what happened with
charlie yesterday against mr beast when charles
started playing a little too quickly mr beast
found great ideas to even trap charles queen so
you have to be careful you don't get overconfident
but todd mikko right now took on c5 and ludwig now
sees that the queen can go gobble up that night
yeah this is overwhelming right now oh she
didn't move her bishop her bishop is free
right does she create a threat but lovely true
i miss that nobody can just take well it happens
right because you think about the bishop was
hanging a second ago and now f4 is just like
maybe we'll tunnel on that bishop but the queen
needs to be taken care of first and larry can
just take this pawn on f4 and continue
with the attack against the white king
so yeah it looks really good for
ludwig he obviously won the first game
he's the much higher rated player uh very
experienced and i actually didn't see any
games from code miko in the last few
days after her match against charlie
so maybe she wasn't practicing or maybe
she was getting coaching that i didn't see
yeah i'm not sure if she's doing any off stream
coaching well you could have lent a hand yeah i
should have as a friend i should have pitched in
a little more this could be on you but she was
banned for a very long time oh so well that's
not good that's not going to help yourself yeah
i think she needs your coaching though well
we'll set up a time we'll get in there sometimes
it's important to have someone small brain to
small brain you know what i'm saying because
donya will talk to me let me talk to me and i'll
be like stop i don't understand the thing you're
saying it seems like you do understand
things they're saying because you took
levy's advice played the stonewall you
had some lessons i love the stonewall
so you took the advice you learned so i yeah but i
didn't understand the stonewall until i literally
broke it down in a weird way that i understood it
like the f file represents frozen and we play with
anna and elsa it's it's very confusing but that's
how i understand it i didn't know that's how
yeah i mean elaborate sounds my teachers
have a really hard job is all we could say
i think that's where's olaf in the equation
olaf doesn't play he's not invited he melted
oh that got sad real yeah well i mean yeah there's
something does come out well there are kids oh i
know i know there are kids that watch chess.com
i get the complaint emails okay just stay off
tuesdays and thursdays from 8 pm to 10 i'm on
chess.com don't watch if you're easily offended
i'm sorry i can't change for you it's fair and
well ludwig does not take this bishop on c5
you mentioned that a while ago that that bishop
could have been captured and even at this moment
the bishop was still under attack so a lot of it
going for his development putting his queen why is
he not taking that i don't understand because
he just knows it's free we need some material
for the post-match interview so i don't know the
answer let's save that off for him he's laughing
though and he's also rewinding in his game
he's he's playing with his foot have we been in
so four turns each we've just let this hang here
that's [ __ ] absurd
nine it's crazy because i know that mikko this
is why chess and i hate to break it to a lot
of people watching this is why chess does not
equal iq i know that miko is smarter than ludwig
1000 million percent but then when people are
like oh he's she's bad at chess so she's stupid
oh gosh get off your high school she moves to
e1 she's a genius yeah those takes are terrible
snap intakes are terrible so it's mate let's
thank you no it's got the thinking music on
all right fun little uh pin here oh
he's got this cutie is a checkmate on the next
move if the king goes there if he brings his
knight in wow this is such a sick checkmate oh
wow yeah i see that what a dope mate yep okay
no no i don't know his every move but
sometimes i can get a read and he's he's pumped
he's pumped he's pumped and do nothing mikko
is fine okay mikko will survive yes and has
not been doing that much chess blood reggie is
grinding as you although he has not had time
to change his sweatpants because he's working so
hard in his chest yeah that's true he did shower
today though so that's very exciting for us he's
making progress i mean you got to be proud of him
yeah it's baby steps sometimes you just have to
lower expectations so that way we can appreciate
the little things i'm excited to see how miko um
takes on the consolation bracket yeah i think that
with some training and a little more experience
that me codemigo can do really well uh she just
had such a tough two matches against charlie
who's been practicing very hard and against
two of the higher rated players in the field
i'm just here i think i actually think and
this is being honest and it might upset some
people i think that the consolation bracket is
more fun to watch because you can't you can't
you never can guess what's going to happen
compared to you know higher level it's it's
very you people know theories and they know
lines and they know all that stuff that i don't
even know if i'm using the right words you are
theory is right yeah opening lines variations yeah
that's crazy but i i just like i like watching bad
chess i think it's more fun i don't want to get
better at chess because then it's it's less fun
to me it's just harder and it requires more
thinking and that that's not fun am i crazy
do you love hard chess chess is fun you know i
like it but now that you put it in those terms
now you feel bad about your hobby yeah what am i
supposed to say now i feel like it's not kind of
singled out you can say it stays fun because
it's just like a more of a challenge it does
stay fun because it's kind of like endless in a
way where you learn something new every game and
if that weren't the case then magnus carlsen he
car they would be perfect players which nobody is
and so they're the best players in the world
out there and yet they still can make mistakes
so there's always something to learn from but if
you get too good don't you go insane that's like
a thing they say about chess players all right
it's time to go to break and when returned we will
have ludwig and code miko in for interviews okay
i played 57 bullet games on the 15th and that is
like a long day for me i don't play on my i hardly
ever play on my second account or third account
um yeah but he plays 46 games of rapid you know
rapid rocks was playing lcs today yes
it's gonna be very exciting oh that
reminds me um i gotta go at six because cog is
actually gonna play so dude sir dosh is just
bill diff honestly like sir josh
has built that he's played 46 games
like yesterday on my longest day of
chess streaming this whole week i've
played 57 games of bullet this
guy's played 46 games of rapid
hello chess.com hello everybody
watching pogchamps i am so hyped dude
honestly sir dosh is just crazy
like he's played way too much chess
like how much has he played this entire week
i'm just like stalking one of my students
he's played 272 games this week let's see how many
i've played and keep in mind i'm like a full-time
chess content creator i played 104 he's played
almost triple the amount of games i've played in
a singular week no i'm not friendzoning somebody
again okay we're past that we're past that yeah
and i play bullet like he's played a 272 games
on rapid like if you just do the time calculation
how many hours is he spending
on chess like per day
how many is that like how how many hours i mean
how many hours has he streamed 10 hours easy
like does he have a life i mean okay
never mind forget i asked that question
he does not have a life i already
know the answer to that it's fine
but like wow it's actually just crazy like
because sometimes he plays really well and
then sometimes he's just like straight ends you
know like this last game we looked at he just
straight into it but then the game before that
he was doing really well so i think honestly
you just think he's like take a chill pill i
hope he's actually taking that bath and not
don't forget guys i'm actually following him
on live chest to make sure he's not playing
any chest while he's taking his bath so
that he can actually relax a little bit
yeah i mean look it's okay to not have a life
but it's another thing to be so try hard that
you play he's playing so much he's playing so much
he's actually playing a real chess head too no
like i'm literally like babysitting his mental
as well so um i'm literally like babysitting his
mental to make sure that he does not die during
the matches and also it's really funny because
i saw another tweet the other day about how he
wanted a chef because he keeps living a dj life
and i'm like maybe he played one less rapid
game a day he could actually cook his own food
maybe maybe
like just maybe if he play one less
rapid game he could cook you know
like i don't know is that is that a wild
gossip is that is that a crazy concept
like if he just plays one less game he he has
time to do a lot like okay me cooking is that
a crazy concept it's never gonna happen me
cooking is not gonna happen i actually was
supposed to go out and buy groceries today and
then so josh wanted okay so i was like okay okay
but it's fine it's fine like i will i will
eat at some point i will eat at some point
he's literally hiring a chef i know i need
a higher chef too but it's okay i mean he's
streaming around 3k hours a year i guess that's
kind of crazy it's actually pretty insane but like
like okay when i played him look at
okay like i'm obviously instructing
him through all of these openings but he
actually picked up this opening pretty fast
at least i hope he did i think he's gonna come
back and be like oh [ __ ] i forgot everything
so now i'm stressed because
maybe i stress him out too much
thanks my girl for the tier one
thank you welcome to the pool party
i i i think like maybe i would have
stressed him out too much but it's fine
i will not do a cooking stream i
haven't eaten breakfast yet it's
currently 5 p.m i need to go eat some
breakfast but he has a second account
i'm gonna stream his match no i
have to watch clg play i think cogs
and we return with the players a lot
of we congrats on the 2-0 score there
and first question is when's the last time you
change your sweatpants okay can cutie cinderella
never be accepted to do commentary again if
she's gonna harass me and talk [ __ ] on me
i changed my sweats i changed them oh okay finally
oh finally mine arse i worked out this morning and
i was wearing a dirty shirt for a workout what am
i supposed to wear a button down now for workouts
no it was like three days old dirty covered in
hot sauce oh yeah no it's a working man's shirt
i'm a working man i wear a working man's
shirt you play video games on a computer
not even i react to stuff it's different video
cases okay and i broke a sweat so look at this
so i'm it's hard to work stressed him out i
was stressed out on the italian game really
yeah you played a pretty tight italian at
the start and i don't know what i was doing
no way are you being sarcastic no being dead
ass and then you made like eight blunders then
i was fine but until then i was pretty nervous
yeah we do have to say again the argument of
being good at chess does not necessarily equal
high iq ludwig had a hard time finding the link
to this meeting even though he's had it so
just more um discord channel it's different
research no from the playing chess i've found
that most chess players actual dog water in
the head they just put all their stock and
iq points into uh figuring out moves and uh
you know what since i'm also dog water in the
head i'm trying to get good at this game as well
it would be nice to be good at
something except for you hes
you in the opening here if we go through the moves
i think that what loving was saying is you did a
very good opening plan with your bishop about
the c4 because you're starting to put pressure
on black's king and you then move the same piece
twice so by moving the bishop a second time you
delayed your other development whereas if you
had castled first and brought some of your other
pieces out it could be more difficult for ludwig
to meet but when you brought the piece out another
time and then you did a good job of protecting
the bishop the problem was that your bishop had
no more squares to go to so ludwig was able to
recognize that and then moved his knight away
after this where when he came for your king and
he plays now your bishop is out of squares because
your pawn your two pawns are taking it away oh you
[ __ ] blocked yourself yeah i can see that now
yeah that was that's not how i would have
phrased it but you know i've discovered uh
a lot of the things in the way i phrase
things are not how the chess world would
uh it's uh you know remind us of what's wrong with
the chess world again i want to hear all of it
did i did i bait the producers into going
to me when i was when i seemed distraught
that was my five head play of the day uh look
there's nothing wrong with the chess world it's
just that sometimes chat can be a little harsh
against the people who uh who sign up for this
tournament and at the end of the day they're
just just.com is trying to get viewers right hey
it doesn't matter if mr beast goes 0-18 you
got mr b's viewers here that's that's all
we need go the game or something right isn't
the quote start start start it up rev it up
why are you singling mr beast out he
played really well in his two matches
well because i like mr beast and i feel like
if i single anyone else out i'll feel mean
i don't mind with mr b's i think jimmy can handle
it oh code mika what's the experience women
like for you learning the game and you know
just getting started and you had two tough
opponents thus far how are you feeling as you
get more matches on your belt um i'm having fun
i just started playing just not too long ago so
i want to keep playing and get better and better
but i've been having a lot of fun moist and
ludwig is really nice so it's really nice to play
again you don't have to lie yeah wait did you say
ludwig is nice yeah that looks nice i didn't know
he has such hygienic problems he always seems
so fresh and clean on the stream all the time
i'm minty i smell great no you look like you smell
great but i guess looks can be very deceiving
thank you cutie for that i feel like this is
mostly you're doing miko is a dear friend of mine
so it's nice to hear yeah well amigo
are you going to do any lessons maybe
with cutie cinderella any more lessons
mikko i would love to do more lessons
with you can you teach me how to beat
ludwig well i can't even beat ludwig oh
which in this case i don't know just frankly i
mean chess chess.com does have the four player
modes so maybe me miko and hess against you
ludwig well maybe 2v2 me and has first youtube
boys versus girls i am i for sure am i just think
really i love this boys versus girls idea i would
love to latch on that house would you rather be
on our team or his team everything's great cool
for me yeah well speaking of buggers you have
one more match-up left against charlie yeah any
friendly words for charlie i found out i don't
know how someone knew this that i in lifetime
six in nine against charlie uh i have won nine
games he has won six nice so my goal is to draw it
okay so you're planning to draw your games yeah
i want to draw both games otherwise we lose it
yeah sounds like a great thing to hear from
somebody that you've uh been trying to help
win games well you know as uh in chess the fun
fact drawing can oftentimes be as good as winning
some people at lower levels might not go for draws
when they should true and who does mikko play next
mr beast oh that'll be a juicer miko you're going
to lose i think mr beast is going to prep opening
moves so whatever you do just don't play what
you've been playing make up something brand new
really yeah he look he's a savant he had every
move i played and mapped out so eight moves out oh
yeah he's a little he's a little cuckoo we'll just
play the italian everyone plays the italian right
i'm going to teach you something
called the stonewall mika what's that
no that's what you should say gotta get over
the stone we love the stonewall you've been
playing it for a year just do anything else
say just try something it's always stonewall
this michelin taught me this occasionally you
want to talk about you want to talk about that
anyway anything else you want to add well
why am i getting throwback to me i don't
want to get involved in this situation here in
fact cutie cinderella we are co-commentators
we're completely equal here anything you'd
like to say to ludwig he um as an adult man
uh he still wets the bed and i want you guys to
know that wait what all right see you guys later
uh-oh i don't know how to leave the
call i don't want to leave the place
why do you still wet the bed get me out of the [
__ ] call producers dirty twenty-five i figured
it out i figured out i'm leaving i'm leaving
i don't want it that way you have to wear them
well we love having the players involved here
cutie cinderella i think you did a great job
of sufficiently exposing ludwig you know thank you
thank you it might not have been true but at least
it made him laugh not him the chat yes you are
now a fan favorite for sure and ludwig he wins to
nothing he's been a favorite of many of the
commentators they've been impressed by his play
today kodmiko was outmatched and honestly the
next one we have in front of us that's the matchup
that many people have been waiting for because
that's the heavyweight battle of benji fishy
and sardoche so before we go to our a
break and come back for that third round
any thoughts on that matchup cutie i am really
excited for that i think this is going to be
some high level gameplay from both of these
two and um i am totally gonna understand what's
going on the entire time um because i too play
above a thousand and it should be great to watch
some people that are also as good as me and
play things like the um aficionados and stuff
it's about time and well we're going to take a
quick break before we do we just want to give
another shout out to guayaqui for helping make
pogchamps possible as gwaiki's celebrates 25 years
of regenerative yerba mate they're sharing cases
to celebrate spam the guayaqui emote in chat for
your chance to win four pillars of regeneration
to heal all nations we work with and not against
because we are a part of this we've never been
apart from this saw hands feel through the soils
past our feet touch on the blades of grass raid
all these voices into a beautiful tapestry find
those similarities we all share in these breaths
that we breathe this home of ours sustains us but
needs us so together we'll move through this
long night and inspire us all to come to life
well i eat i'm deciding right
now do i want do i want sushi
macdonald
okay wait what i want i i got italia i kind
of wanted italian today let's see what uber
eats actually has i'm really hungry i need
a chef for 36. kebab you guys like kebabs
i can't get that so that's pretty sad
i kind of want indian food again though
i know i love floating that's pretty fun
oh i'm on chess tv uh
i'm literally just debating
what i want to eat honestly
i'm very hungry but i'm way too
emotionally invested in this upcoming match
so play one less rapid game cook but you don't
understand i'm like i need i actually need
uh
he needs to relax a little bit i mean this
one's easy he just has to play rook there
are my quarter french we
should probably put the process
from french i i'm not french at all i can just
speak french because i lived in france and i
grew up in canada i have to adapt yeah he did it
he's 80 he's almost 900 in puzzles this is crazy
okay okay he's gonna get 1900 before his game i
mean i guess that's gonna make up for him dropping
like 50 rating today so pizzas want a chestnut
gold twitch pull all right guys i'm ordering pizza
did they actually vote okay i will actually get
pizza because the viewers the viewers wanted it
if you guys want if you guys want a pizza
i'll get pizza i mean honestly i'm up for
whatever so okay let's order some really
good pizza what's something really awesome
okay so pizza um i mean i live in toronto
do you guys know pico do you guys should
i get like italian pizza anything except like
anything except pizza pizza pizza is pretty good
we're getting pizza oh i love
this question because it's gonna
this is gonna be the biggest debate all
right i'm muting sir josh for a moment
do you like pineapple on pizza
pineapple pizza yes or no type one in the chat
if yes one's in the chat if you like pineapple
i'm not gonna lie i actually like pineapple
on pizza and i have not had hawaiian pizza
in a hot minute 1.5 dude i actually
really really really enjoy hawaiian pizza
we are no it's pretty good it's pretty good no
desert i see you saying cut transmission on the
chest.com chat okay i see you guys i see you guys
um okay i think do you guys know little caesar i
don't actually like little caesars i think i'm
gonna go for something that's a little bit more
uh not chained and more of a like
home baked i really want pizza on
a fire that sounds really good no you can't
unsubscribe waiver you just subscribe today
oh i could get caesar salad to go oh yeah actually
you know what oh i'm so hungry right now i'm so
hungry okay i'm gonna get pizza with caesar
salad this is really nice um restaurant okay
i'm trying to not dox my address here but like
this looks good this looks so good i love this
this is gonna look really good okay this is like
a classical italian kind of restaurant i guess we
have around here um there's a lot of good stuff i
don't even know what i want i didn't leak anything
chill uh but pizza in canada is not very
cheap unfortunately um as you guys know
there's this thing called pizza pizza and
pizza pizza is pretty terrible but it's cheap
pizza if you want good quality pizza it's pretty
expensive so yeah oh chat wanted pepperoni pizza
okay we'll get pepperoni pizza um all right
so pepperoni pizza just don't forget order
yeah i'll actually order how expensive it's like
15 bucks for like a medium-sized pizza if it's
not from like a shitty place you know like
a terrible place pepperoni wins on chess.com
it's actually pretty expensive pizza there's
a lot of different pizza choices there's north
of brooklyn pizaria this sounds medium pepperoni
pizza is 20 bucks by the way 20 bucks by the way
that's a bit of a scam i'm not gonna
lie i might just go back to pizza pizza
like that's kind of expensive i'm not lying i'm
not joking that's like a little bit expensive
but like i feel like there has to be something a
little like something that's not pizza pizza bad
pizza but like not that i deserve a good pizza i
mean it's 15 canadian bucks so like it's not like
let me play you 1v1 chess for 100 best out of
three games blitz rating 900 smile the last
time somebody did this it was a little bit sus
that's all i'm gonna say that's all i'm gonna say
but like i'm down to do it just not
today
so
hawk champs 3 is presented by grip 6 and grip 6
has sold out of the chest team wallets but check
out their wide selection of while it's available
they still have the amazing chess belts 3 options
available the queen king and knight all with 3
different strap options find them at go.chest.com
grip6 judy i think they need a cutie cinderella
belt honestly uh well you forgot to mention they
can use code pogchamps 20 for 20 off uh hello
i'm trying to save the discounts for myself
i know those things run out quick shoot okay
fine okay fine i won't tell anybody um yeah
i don't think we need a cutie belt
i don't want to be closer to any of
buddy's um anyway uh so what are we looking
at now oh wow well community outreach the
complete opposite of what we were just talking
about so chess.com will match up to 100 000 of
the viewing community's donations during the event
donations will be given to participants preferred
non-profit organizations in the split you see
on screen in front of you and just a reminder
of what organizations those are the players have
made their choices el sardos and xqc still need
to make theirs but we see unicef we see the one
drop foundation and across the board you know
mr beast st jude's a lot of great causes yeah i i
personally i love the humane society i always um
donate my money to the humane society which is
bad because i see that's critical's charity and
now i automatically want him to win but that'll
make ludwig sad so i'm in a weird spot there but
i love i love the humane society i love the
work that they do so we'll see what happens
yeah hard to root for anybody based on these
causes so many great ones and well we will have
the final games of the group stage and after
the group stage we have the bracket so the
championship bracket it will look like this
the group a winner takes on the second place
from group b on the other side of the bracket the
group b winner takes on second place from group a
c and d do the same themselves and so we will
see some great matches we don't know what they
will be because the results are not in
but if we look at the current standings
we have potential match ups for example of daniel
negranu taking on the loser of today's match
between sardosh and benji fishy and the winner
of benji fishy sutterish will take on whoever
finishes second place in group b so those kind of
matchups wow clear yeah okay i'm interested to see
yeah how this game just turns out i'm not sure
like i've said i've said it a hundred times
today i feel benji and sardosh they're just both
they're both so good that i'm just gonna pretend
like i have hot takes and chat this is what
i need you to do i just need you to say yep
and go along with it okay no matter what i say i
yep i'm with you i got your back i agree with you
thank you thank you so much and you just timed
all the yeps because here they come and what
people are about to be pumped about is tomorrow's
matchups because we have four in store we start
with pokeman taking on rubius okay my queen my
queen pokeyman please go back re-announce that
you'll be seeing her twice look at her she's there
two times on the screen because group b will have
another match up daniel negrano taking
xqc then you have rain wilson and logic
fighting for first place in group c and then
finally xqc and pokemon that matchup that
was postponed it will be happening tomorrow 4 20
p.m and it's between xqc and who again remind me
queen the queen pokemane everyone please
bow how do you they prove that they bowed
uh they spam yep got it so you're just
continuing to farm the yeps yep got it and well
speaking of farming you can take down
not say these players but their bots
farm some rating off of them pokemon bot ludwig
code miko xqc nico and mr beast all of these bots
of the players who are taking part in i played all
of these bots last night actually every single one
how'd you do good i beat every single one whoa
yeah i had the biggest problem with mr beast
actually is it what was it about mystery i had
to play i had to yeah he was too he gave me too
much money i was like wow uh i had to play him
three times before i beat him i don't know why
maybe he just felt bad honestly my
chat was telling me that it was because
his opening countered the stonewall
and all i use is the stonewall
and if mr beast is known for anything it's not
his youtube prowess not his great philanthropic
causes it's for knowing how to out prepare
his opponent's chest from it yeah yeah
yeah i hate when that happens yeah well you took
down all the bots this is why there can't be a
bot of you because then people will win and we
can't see cutie lose right that's what they keep
telling me but i think it's a lie well there's
a bot of me i didn't ask them for it in fact i
didn't want it to happen but it was against my
permission i really didn't want that to happen
i asked weekly yeah and that's why is he
the opposite what happened i didn't want one
and one was made you want one and some it's just
maybe just just don't want it can i have hesses
just give me hesis he doesn't even want his same
skill level come on you haven't seen that's messed
up i think can we make it happen chess.com
can cutie cinderella just take over my butt
i feel like that works well forever give it a
hair a little longer yeah they said no smiley face
disappointing we do have a lot to smile about
because we have had generous donations from andre
we also had the paddywagon a hundred dollars chess
for charity thank you so much for your generous
support reminder to everybody that chess.com
is matching up to a hundred thousand dollars
in donations all going to charity of the players
choosings so this is a great cause and we really
appreciate it i love twitch usernames i don't know
if i mean yours is easy gm has very professional
i had an interview with a danish newspaper about
chess actually why danish how did that happen i
don't know okay it just happened okay um because
i'm known for my great chess plays plays and um
and they had to say what's your name and i said
blaire and then he said what's your username on
twitch and i had to be like beauty cinderella
so i only imagine how paddywagon69 feels wait
why just say with pride what's wrong
with cutie cinderella it's a great name
because i have to spell it out i
have to be like oh the letter q yeah
the letter t and then cinderella like the
princess yes i'm 26. like you know like
yeah like it's just a little embarrassing i
don't want to say so we're going to take a
quick break and when we return we will be ready
with the benji fishy sardosh matchup stay tuned
we're going to take a quick break and we'll
turn we will be ready with the benji face no
not a break stay tuned no not more what okay
let's let's watch someone else on twitch then
um oh dudes they're featuring me okay
then i'm gonna do some puzzles let's go
again let's go again let's go again let's
let's watch someone else on twitch then um
let's go back to puzzles okay here we go
chuck mate chuck mate chuck mate chuck mate
chuck mate chuck mate chuck mate check
checkmate check make the queen uh checkmate
you can obviously take b3 that's
probably just check check and mate
check and take the rook take the bishop um take
the juicer check mate there's obviously just
takes and checkmate checkmate white
pawns go up the board so you take
you push bring the king take and then
you make a queen that's good checkmate
now you just take take and just take uh check
and mate there you go believe it's check
another 20 subs thank you for the 140 subs that
you've gifted today thank you so much my man
you are amazing thank you um let's go shock
let's take the juicer let's take the queen
let's go shock and then we
go d7 and make the queen
now we just take fossilize the bishop take the
juicer we just take we go check take the juicer
uh i assume you can go here go thank you for the
great content and countless hours of entertainment
so king g3 i actually i'm a little bit confused as
to what this puzzle is exactly for other games or
shows i don't know what it is it's because king
e3 is all no okay it's got to be here don't be
stupid okay you go check and potential ice skater
in the back now you go here eat eat fork and eat
the queen um there's queen d8 here and now you
just go check take the queen this is good i
think you can just go checking a7 that should
be right just push under cr8 take the juicer
now you can just take oh it's c5 moving trying
to move too fast and theme with the uh with the
show okay let's still get to 50 before before they
come back let's go oh wait the rook is pinned wait
the rook is pinned okay let's let's start again
let's start again the rook is pinned um let's go
this is the uh the arabian checkmate you know
you always want to learn some of these checkmates
check that's winning let's go takes you
to cutie jelly for the five gifted thank
you so much to qt jolly qt jelly for the five
gifted thank you so much at first i was about
to say cutie i was about to say cutie jelly
cinderella let's go here let's go get here um
let's take a checkmate um uh is it quincy one i
think i think it's queen b2 if i'm not mistaken
no i'm just wondering okay
let's let's let's just go again
let's do one more yeah i was about to say cutie
jelly cinderella yeah okay last one we'll get
we'll get to 50. how much time do i have before
they return to the official broadcast you guys uh
takes and takes let's go check and let's take
um 40 seconds to get get to 50 okay check
drop back um it's good take just takes that's good
take the juicer on d3 checkmate um check check
take the queen 54 underscore check check cakes
that's good just takes that's good just check
take the queen that's good i assume it's king g4
and then take the queen that's good you go chuck
chuck take the queen that's good um takes takes
it's good uh takes takes takes takes takes takes
takes check takes takes um i think it just takes
there check d4 take a juicer i think it's rook f1
if i'm not crazy um am i crazy though wait there's
also queenie two wait a second i gotta be careful
wait a second it's actually not trivial no no it
is i'm stupid check check takes takes and then
you move the king to the corner you take and then
you slow dive underscore just subscribe take take
move the king how many times i say takes takes
there way too many okay obviously he takes takes
and we return ready for our final match of the
day that is between benji fishy and sardoche
two of the top competitors they've been working
their tails off beauty now's the time you got
to make a choice is it benji is it sardosh okay
listen if you've ever watched my stream you know
and this is so irrelevant and chat some of
you probably don't know i'm have always been
a massive bjergsen simp um i'm a league of legends
girl that's where i started was league of legends
and sartosh is also a mid laner in league of
legends and anybody who's ever been maybe a
competition for bjergsen uh-uh i'm not your fan so
i'm going all benjy here wow well benji needs all
the support he can get because sardocia's rating
is 14.50 what what have they been feeding this guy
oh i don't know i'm nervous but i i really hope
for benji oh apparently he's a jungler this is so
awkward oh um never mind you'd like to take back
everything i said a lot of awkward moments here
i feel like it gets less awkward if you just
make it public right i just put candy in my
mouth and it was like a weird distraction yes
and uh well moves not being played that quickly
so both players taking their time i wonder what
their coaches said to them about the other player
because they have been improving and grand master
eulogic hammer has been coaching benji fishy and
this move c4 so a lot of people in polychams don't
actually challenge the center with c4 they often
play bishop f4 for the london system instead we
see c4 and c6 by sardos this is to me showing that
they've really studied because he's creating a
pawn chain rather than taking the pawn c4 directly
yeah that's what i was going to
say that's so great i would like um
um yeah i'm joking i'm joking i don't know
they're both good i don't know what to say yes
i thought you were physically choking for a
second you just told me you were talking of
candy and i was worried for your hair nervous
this is the first time i've choked the entire
episode you're screaming and saying
you're choking and that is a hazard
all right i was worried some people
like that um anyway uh back to the game
oh gosh well black has the
pawn chain towards the center
white devotes the bishop to d3 so often when
the bishop develops now is the time that black
takes because you don't get to recapture in one
move but the players are leaving the tensions
the sign that they've been improving that
they've been studying because i think when
you're less experienced you take as quickly
as possible when given the opportunity i agree
join me join me when you look at this position
what are you thinking about there's
not a single piece has been traded i
think it's very different than how i play i
get very excited and any low elo players that
are watching if you're like me i would just i
would want to take take take take take that's
what keeps me entertained um i am sad that no one
has used the stonewall opening this entire day
i think that that's disappointing magnus carlson
used it recently and that was exciting for me
um but it just doesn't get enough attention and
that's what i know about chess is the stonewall
so i will always talk about the stonewall so
do you think that magnus watched your stream
absolutely all right just making sure that you're
on the same page i think he might have yeah being
inspired by other creators that's the sign of a
brilliant chess player yes but here would it be um
oh never mind never mind i was gonna say would it
be what would you do next here well the thing is
not a single piece has been traded so that's i
would say the uh struggle right now is what to
do because nothing's been traded and benji plays
b3 to protect his pawn support with another pawn
and well sodor says i'm going to play h6
and they're actually playing a really high
level game this to this point taking on f6
would unnecessarily give up the bishop pair
whereas this knight's not really going anywhere
it can move but then you're willing to trade the
bishops and this knight has nowhere good to move
so by not trading qt they're leaving this tension
and creating difficulties for their opponent
so it's just not restricting their opponent's
chances to play something active i mean i've
said i've said we love fortnite you know i'm
a big for what are you doing ah you haven't
said where you want to go where do i want to
go yeah who do you think's going to win um
well i don't know that's why i asked you i
just thought that you would figure it out and
i don't know you want to place bets i don't
is that legal chess.com ten dollars hess i
have ten dollars on benchy but then i now
have to have a rooting interest i stay neutral
on these things are we supposed to say neutral
you have ten dollars on benji that's brave and no
odds because charge is the higher rate of player
[ __ ] so i mean i i kind of want to take those
odds never mind it's like if you even bet a high
rate player that feels good for me you take
it back i mean feel like we didn't shake okay
well b5 was played so sardoce is taking up more
space you sure that it's too late yeah mm-hmm
looking forward as ten dollars okay anyway
so b5 played challenging this pawn structure
another time but benji doesn't even need to move
it because his pawn is defending and his bishop
is defending again and it's 10 moves in cutie
zero trades i'm sure you're maulding over there
i'm losing my mind yeah i was told
by levy always take whenever you can
you said that yeah always take even if you
lose pieces he's my favorite coach oh okay
that's good strategy sometimes i can get behind it
and levy is now pulling out all of his hair in
chat he's never said that to me but if i said it
then it's true i didn't think he said it until
he makes a video about it you're not believable
i had i had one night uh i don't know if you guys
know a a rook king mate is very difficult and it's
really hard for me and i had one night it was like
two in the morning and i was just spamming levy
until he got on a call with me to walk me through
it so he's a good he is a good he's a good coach
i'll take back my joke and he taught you your
favorite opening so and he taught me the stonewall
sounds good my favorite opening so that's
something a great coach inspiring causing you
to you know fall in love with aspects of the game
i think there's nothing more that needs to be said
and well benji has done something i think is
really good but you're not going to be happy
about it because instead of trading he pushed
his pawn forward to c5 creating interesting
connection and black's pieces are kind of like
stepping on each other's toes this pawn on c5
is a big thorn it takes away the b6 square
from that knight the bishop on e7 can't
really move because this configuration here
says you're limited in scope so that's wow oh
you're a fan of that move it sounds like perhaps
yeah perhaps a trade here right because the bishop
that's his option he could take or he could just
ignore it so he does okay there we go we have a
trade they are recognizing that pieces can come
off the board don't need to keep them all proud of
this development one of the big things here cutie
is this pawn structure for white is really strong
and when you have a pawn chain the pawn chain
is only as strong as the base of its chain so
the f2 pawn is very safe so what black wants to do
in the near future is play e5 to start chiseling
at the pawn chain to create the bass closer to
black pieces and make it easier to attack it yeah
that's what i always do too i know you do you're
a stonewall player so you know about pawn chains
yeah i wonder um i wonder what's
going through their heads right now i
i'm they're on call with each other
right i hope they're talking some smack
while on call while playing why not
so she's just quietly listening to music come on
is just like the soothing music but yeah
kind of motivating at the same time
what's your go-to chess playlist
oh i typically don't listen to music when
i'm playing but if i am i'm just getting
like a random kind of hype music sometimes let's
get kind of popular music leon bridges always
can listen to him no matter what i'm doing okay
all right okay i can't tell if that was an okay of
approval or okay like what's wrong with you who's
leon bridges whoa whoa that bridges is so awesome
yeah you're gonna have to go on spotify later i
can send you some songs i got you in discord i'm
a taylor swift and taylor swift only family okay
i would like her bought on chess.com please but
like she would say some really sad things that she
lost she's like i'm gonna write a song about this
and it'll just be a sad one and this position is
looking kind of sad for black right now because
benji bringing his pieces in and this knight can
go to e5 so it's not like black is in danger of
losing the game anytime soon it's just hard to
play this way when you don't have any active plans
and white is the one trying to press for it yeah
come on benji take that knight to e5 and then you
get a pawn right hypothetically you get that
pawn on c6 right and how do you like that bishop
on c8 cutie that bishop on c8 is just stuck he is
stuck the tall pawn that's what we call that yeah
like every step cyst you've ever had he is just
wedged in there yeah it can't get out and that's
the problem with black's position and white's
pieces are better pretty much every piece except
for this knight on e4 for black is worse and a4
that you saw the engine it kind of dropped a bit
and i didn't like the move b4 i think that at
that moment soto should have taken on a4 and
then open the position up maybe try to trade
bishops and finally get his pieces out but the
engine says white's still much better even in
that scenario all right best ten dollars i've
ever won wait you took the bet back no wait what
we agreed on it okay sure i see how this goes yeah
actually maybe what starters did is even better
because he planted his knight potentially on the
c3 square and white has this good known e5
but in comes that knight to c3 that could
be problematic good thing we never shook on it so
wait you keep going back and forth i'm so confused
so do we have ten dollars on this or not we'll
see okay i get it if you win i owe you ten dollars
nothing happens correct yes that is true it
takes a while for chess players to process
these things i understand and well cutie
benji does have that bishop that you like
in the stonewall and it is aiming well trying to
aim towards black's king so at some point we may
see the move pawn f3 to kick that knight and
open up the diagonal that is my favorite mate
he's checking the h7 yeah
mm-hmm it's the only one i know
is that ladder mate is that your favorite
uh bishop that's a rook is bishop on b7
no he's so stuck i don't know what he's doing
oh he just protected that pawn from the night i
understand now well that's sad when your piece is
defending just a mere pawn and that's why pawns do
so well when they're connected with one another
you don't have to use a greater resource to fit
to defend the least valuable people g chat oh and
aaron at the queen oh i was staring at the chat
staring at the queen yes do not blend your queen
i don't think benji will he looks really well
in fact we just have his forehead both foreheads
you just see one eyeball of benji's peering
at the board it's kind of creepy i've seen
enough horror movies to know how this might end
oh queen d2 played all right saving the queen
and there's just no tension in the position the
atmosphere is tense i mean they're just trying
to figure out what to do but there's no pieces
attacking one another and no pawns that
can be traded and i like the move by
stardust there to trade off white's most
aggressive piece this 95 or this knight
on f6 that wasn't exactly doing anything
yeah the clocks are pretty even too yes
just no now just under five minutes for benji and
540 for sardosh and well i like to move 97 trying
to make some trades what do you think is this
knight on c3 it bothers me do you think that white
at some point soon should try to bring the
knight back from f4 and kick it out of there
i think i think that's a great idea uh i guess
i guess that's that is that's what i would do
and well i guess and benji wants you
to win those ten dollars come on benji
come on you know it's a good move trading off
black's most aggressive piece there we go yep
there goes the trade and this bishop on b7 is so
bad and a big problem is maybe you'd want to trade
that bishop on a6 but you can't do that with this
queen and bishop on the same diagonal covering the
a6 square so first you see the capture here
and now what white can do clean up the board
you start pushing pawns on the king side like to
advance your pieces here as black doesn't have
good control so they still have that h7 check
available that's right if we can line the queen
and the bishop up there that could be a checkmate
so we have many ideas with trying to line up the
queen bishop expanding with f4 and maybe keep
pushing the pawns and black feels a little stuck
and chat is all in french now yeah yeah i do
uh i do speak a bit of french do you understand
it's going too fast for me no i don't it's
way too fast i think they're singing a song
very good chat you guys are you guys are
talented seriously impressive copy pasting
yeah yeah the best and so sorry i was thinking
now it's even on the clock again this is probably
the best match i've seen thus far in apollo jumps
all due respect the other players but this feels
really intense and neither player giving up ground
rook a7 that is a move that you would not expect
and look at benji go pushing upon ford and i'm
guessing rook a7 was played to go rook a8 there it
is and bishop es6 he recognized the need to trade
off his terrible bishop for benji's good one wow
that's that's some five head stuff
and do you know how many hours they've both put
into this game recently i have no idea but i see
that sardosh every time i look at twitch he's
playing or with a new coach i think he was with
nemo just a couple hours ago so he's working very
hard right that's amazing i do not and this it's
intense it's interesting to see how each person
handles the competition yeah i mean it's really
hard work paying off for both of them f5 you
saw the engine drop and the reason why is this
pawn on e5 lost its defender so chest often is
about timing and now that black took this pawn
e5 is going to be one that can quickly get under
attack so rook takes f5 here will defend the pawn
temporarily but then this bishop can slide back to
c8 attack the rook and become useful for a change
that'll be exciting for him could would
it no i was i always do this and i mess up
where i do something strange where i like
sacrifice a rook in order to get that h7
right and that could happen actually because if
you somehow get this rook captured and your queen
can land on f5 there could be a checkmate with the
queen of the bishop but right now if benji plants
his rook on f6 swings his other rook to f1 there
could be a devastating attack against black's king
that would be exciting i hope he sees that
he's thinking about where to move the rook
and rook f6 is the most aggressive square it
also lines up a potential sacrifice you were
talking about sacrificing pieces to go for a
checkmate the rook on f6 could do just that
so benji demon thought but he's getting down to
that just over three minute territory sardosh a
bit ahead in the clock and i think bendy trying to
recognize you know what's changed my rook's under
attack i see that but also what's changed the pawn
on g7 was covering f6 oh okay instead of retreats
and i get that sometimes you worry about putting
your pieces too far up the board but rook on f6
would have kept this pawn in place and created
more threats if the rook's here this pawn's under
attack this pawn's under attack it's challenging
black more than the rope back in f3 but he is
creating that battery right that battery with
the two of them give me one free move i will
gladly take this pawn in f7 so how would you go
about and defending that pawn to here uh is there
maybe a piece that hasn't been doing much
i mean he just has to move that oh i was
thinking he'd move that bishop and then expose
the rook but i guess this is what he's doing
you're right though bishop back was better the
rook on a7 would have protected but look at this
this pawn was under attack but now it's pinned
and if benji sees it bishop takes g6 steals a pawn
did you see benji he kind of threw himself back in
his chair i think he sees it fingers crossed okay
he's got his hand up he feels ready to play his
move he's down under three minutes sardosha had
the clock but that was a big swing if benji
takes that pawn he does he takes it nice okay
and look at this that king is now open sardoche
did not see that coming now that it's on the board
you were talking about that queen getting
in cuny it's looking more and more likely
so that looks like a problem but what can white do
here right it's either i think this is the wrong
move but i i would probably do it would be to take
that pawn with the bishop on yeah and then he's in
check but it doesn't really buy i guess it's just
a waste of a move well it would be a great move
if the rook on a7 were first to capture so
you're looking tactically as a way to distract
but unfortunately after bishop takes up some the
f 8 rook can take back and save the day so i think
benji is best off just retreating his bishop hard
to do when you just stole a pawn you're all up
yeah you're so excited to be up there just
bring it back and this king is still exposed
this is nice this commentary today is nice
because it's just a free chess lesson for me
you know i thought i was the one learning from
you so i could let me teach you the stonewall
anytime i need to learn it i haven't ever
studied it so i would appreciate your guidance
it's great i agree it looks great when when
you win games with it so i don't often but i'm
just trying to you know who's the morale okay i
am getting nervous for benji's time a little bit
i am as well and i think he's trying to figure out
because this bishop is hitting the queen and the
rook on the same diagonal that's a problem for him
he needs to see that his bishop can just retreat
back which saves the material and still leaves
black's king out in the open uh we're spending too
much time and i i don't think he sees it based on
the time consumption no i don't think he sees it
either that's the hardest thing and this is gonna
be very stupid and you guys gonna be like yeah
forehead cutie uh to remember is that your your
bishops can move back ah any sacrifice the rook
i actually don't think it's stupid at all i think
that's a mistake that is very commonly made one of
the hardest things to find in chess is retreating
night moves and treating moves in general are
easily missed all the time and now the
problem for benji is he lost a rook for
a bishop he still has attacking chances but
the rook for bishop dynamic should be good
for sudden if he can handle this well there but
there's still pressure and i don't think that
sodos is out of the woods yet i'm nervous
about the time someone text sardosh something
tell him his refrigerator's running or something
maybe don't text the players because that could
constitute some problematic behavior with a
little cheating you get some texts and moves but
well benji wins i get ten dollars how did you
come up with a refrigerator that's like a thing
you've never gotten that prank call no not a
single time oh is your refrigerator running hess
yeah all the time oh you better go catch it
now you know oh that that hurt to hear yeah
i'm actually upset i know i'm so so is everyone
everyone's upset look at vengeance there's
actually a big attack queen 65 is not a free pawn
don't go take that because rook g3 check you
see that evar skyrocket yeah kingdom's up you
keep giving checks and the king has to go in the
corner massive come on benji we have a minute
so i think that sardoch knows better than to leave
the defense of his king by taking a pawn don't get
greedy here he's already out material hey benji
i need you to focus right now focus on the clock
come up with your move right now that's what
i do and then i always do the wrong move
it's a really good tactic i recommend it maybe
you'll have to coach these players in advance the
next one yeah they would be upset that i wasted
their time i don't think anyone feels that way
it's always a good time which is never a waste
of time so okay so i was thinking he could get
himself the time trouble and his king's the one
that's more open so kitty playing these positions
open king i feel like that's often scarier
than having a material deficit yeah i agree uh
i i think he's pretty safe to start playing oh
oh he did it no my gosh he did it
he called it he's in checkmated by
force come on does he see it i thought it was my
analysis board for a second and then i looked and
no the engine's got he does see it there he
sees it oh gosh oh no queen f6 it's all forest
it's all forces mate it's it's checkmate on
the spot that's it's done and look at sardoce
oh my gosh
i can't believe it
i think 12. he plays fortnight and let's
see when the checkmate happens if we get
a reaction look how happy he is
there he is oh my gosh all right
ten dollars everybody ten dollars what do you mean
ten dollars that's only the first game oh yeah
it's we did on each match oh okay so yeah everyone
in chat owes you ten dollars yep i think that's
fair so go over to the cutie cinderella's channel
and make me holla yeah throw those ten dollars her
wish you called it and that's a huge upset because
sardoche was seen as maybe the favor of the entire
event up with the likes of rain wilson getting a
lot of love logic playing well of course blood is
is too but sardosa's rating is so high and
people said this could be a preview for the
ultimate championship and benji said i'm here to
play i may be young but i can do this thing and he
delivers a checkmate i've actually been saying it
i i've said it on my stream that i think the end
i think benji will go pretty far to of course i
have ludwig all the way i think he is going to
win the whole thing um but i think benji's going
to get really really far playing games like this
he out of the gates was doing extremely well he
let it slip a bit but he had the attack on his
mind the board opened up and sardos you could
tell he just didn't see all the tactics and
he was really upset with himself because he's
like i should have known better i had a feeling
things were off and just a couple moves before the
end here the queen on e7 a very important defender
making sure that the enemy queen doesn't get in
so he spent a lot of time on that move yeah he did
and i wonder if he forgot that the queen
could go to f6 and this is something that
happens all the time because you may see the
check on this diagonal right that's the entire
length of the board but after queen c5 rook
g3 check king agent if you check in the corner
maybe starters was looking at queen c3 to block
the check and say no checkmate for you i'm in fact
i'm just taking advantage but benji says nope up i
go and there goes the checkmate oh great so great
we're impressed look at this chest today huh the
weather's great and the chest is even better see
this is what happens though cutie at first the
position was really close no trades were happening
we were thinking oh come on go get some pieces
off but chess at their level right now it said
it doesn't end with necessarily a queen blonde or
anything like that we need to be patient we need
to wait for opportunities sardosh won in exchange
benji quickly struck back it is one nothing in
benji fishy's favor we'll be back shortly
for more for pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
whole first match because yes i i like i
said when i saw benji play the second game
it was very very good um so i was very
very impressed okay let's uh let's do
more puzzles then in the meantime so i think
we're still being featured on chess.com right
yes we're being featured so let's do puzzles
let me pause this okay this is white to play
and win here there's knight h6 knight g5 there's
also just h6 h7 take the queen this is good oh
from your stonewall cutie that this bishop on
d3 is the most important part of your attack
yeah so you're trying to trade off that bishop
before it even gets out and soter says nope no
trade for you and then look at benji strike right
back in this world wow what is happening here
lots of pawn tension in both sides they're just
hanging out they're getting ice cream together
and hopefully they can do that in a short span
of time it doesn't have to require a huge line
and they're both playing really fast right now i
think this is a mistake on sardosha's part because
he needs to win this game and he has plenty of
time right now so instead of playing bishop to d3
you look at this position with the pawn
tension you want to figure out can i go
and take one of these pawns should i throw in a
check you always want to look for checks maybe
queen a4 check is a good move bishop d3 is by
no means a bad move and benji quickly castles
but it felt like he didn't know what to
do so he felt the urge to play quickly
if you remember game one though he was
the one ahead on the clock yeah and
i'll look at bench he knows the plans this is not
someone memorizing an opening this is somebody
understanding because he brought his bishop back
to e7 he didn't like the pin here and now you have
the bishop on d3 you have the bishop on h4 but
lining up an attack is difficult because one of
the best ways to stop an attack is by creating
threats elsewhere on the board and with this
tension all over the place here in the center
white doesn't have a free hand on the king's
side i like i like benji constantly does that
like that like there's like a word for it that
like serial killer stare at the chessboard just
like looking up at it and it's terrifying i think
i think that gives him a bit of an upper hand
in case sardoche looks at him it's really scary
kubrick kubrick stare that's what it's called
doesn't look like sardosh has been looking up at
the cameras very often he's just been staring down
yeah he's concentrating he's kind of shaking right
now well benji's playing that well it's causing
him some fear and well knight e5 played jumping up
with the knight benji can trade knights that will
hurt white's pawn structure instead he goes queen
c7 to defend the knight but there's a oh there's a
big tactic here knight takes c6 queen takes e6 and
when the pawn takes on d5 i hit your queen and
i hit your bishop on a6 so oh wow yeah there's
tactics like this maybe white should take the
knight first but either way you will take on d5
and this bishop is hanging so let's see what the
players have done no bishop g3 oh interesting
yeah he doesn't he doesn't go for the trades
he keeps the tension and it's a good move
it just so happened that there was a better
move based on the location of the pieces
so much tension here you know what time it is
no i thought there could be a stonewall situation
with that pond going out that is not a stone wall
do you even know the stonewall that's not the
stonewall how dare you i ask you to teach me but
you're too busy teaching pokey and code mikko and
everybody else that's not the stone wall i'm sorry
i'm sorry gm's these days they don't even
know all the freaking openings that's crazy
i'm sorry embarrassing for you honestly well now
you have to take the reins here because i feel
awkward well he's not doing the stonewall is what
i can say he's it's long gone there's no stonewall
left here if he would have done the stonewall that
f pawn would have been on f4 but he did just take
that pawn that's exciting development i was trying
to get the pawn to f4 that was part of my plan oh
well then this is awkward well that's just
the delayed stonewall not quite the same
and nice it's raid benji quickly trading i think
he's gonna keep going he can put a rook on d8
in line with the queen at the end of the road
and there could be some tactics here that favor
black so i think benji can put a rook on d8 he
can also take on d4 start trading some more and
black has no weaknesses in the position
nothing to gang up on and so he should
have the better position between these
two players hmm so who who is up right now
i i can't keep track of the pieces it's
even in terms of material oh okay great
and i'm trying to make the claim that black
is doing very well because you can take on d4
and that would leave white with an isolated
pawn so after pawn 64 for example i see
pawn takes pawns best friends another pawn you
don't have the defense of another pawn so i can
pile up and start attacking you that'd be really
exciting you don't sound that excited i i i just
i looked over at at levy in the chat he said women
gm keck w oh that that's a personal attack and it
that did feel like a personal attack and i don't
know why because we're here watching the same game
levy all right who took your job [ __ ] it
was me i was about to say who's on the big
screen in the answer who's on the big screen
big guy huh who's here yeah so i thought this
sounds like a fractured relationship in
terms of we do chess coaching demolition
i'm the only woman that will go on his stream
i i feel like the thing you could do to hurt
him the most is stop playing the stonewall
like no matter what you say it's not going
to be defective he'd be so happy if i stopped
playing the stone he'd be like finally she's
doing a new opening it's been a year it's been
one year finally but that's loyalty at its finest
oh yeah i don't know it's the only thing
that stuck to my brain it's very obnoxious
that the only voice that sticks in my
brain is levies oh yeah but there's a
lot of content so if you just keep watching the
videos that go up on youtube and there's more
intake and hey that's a a learned voice i
want levy to do more videos with lucy though
where are the lucy videos where's the lucy content
levy oh um yeah maybe he'll analyze these games
with lucy because these games have been good and
more content the merrier oh okay now we're talking
and well look at oh no oh no that's so i get the
point by benji trying to take advantage of the pin
but white has two knights and the
pawn all staring at the e5 square
wow very good idea unfortunately the
execution doesn't quite work in this moment
so he's going to take it with his knight
of course right and that night is the uh
that night uh c night and you can offer us some
trades and pieces and you love that you take on d4
i can take back and for now white is a pawn ahead
and that's not good news for benji although his
position as you can see based on the engine it's
still quite decent because white's gonna have a
hard time keeping that extra pawn and sodosh takes
it we actually are seeing the sequence i have to
take back on e2 with the queen and now benji's
in for a tough think because you can either take
on e4 or take on e5 and he should spend time
calculating the difference between the two
mm-hmm yeah and for the record for any chess
chess chat members that don't understand what
a sense of humor is levy and i are best friends
so yeah we make fun of each other a little bit
but at the end of the day we're best friends
all right levy oh that that changed real quick
yeah well you have to be honest sometimes
unfortunately people don't understand anymore
oh oh oh oh oh oh when pieces are in line
with the queen you go and try to pin them
oh that was a rush decision still a good position
for sardosh but go back a half step here rook to
c1 or queen to c4 you pile up and you pin the
piece and win the piece so this would have been
a great opportunity for starters to
level the match instead he takes on c6
and his idea is that when the queen takes on c6
he will take on d4 white will still be a pawn
ahead so it's a good decision it makes sense but
he had a move that would have netted more material
he did move that really quickly yes do you think
that a clock is just a vital part of the strategy
maybe i mean they seem so close on time um that
maybe he knew that he was just trying to get a
bit of an upper hand makes sense because you
know he had a lead on the clock in the first
game and he had a good position i'm sure he
was analyzing it during the break between the
games so he should be feeling confident about his
chest there was nothing in that first game that
led me to believe that he should feel anything but
good about the way he's been playing and now he
is upon ahead though it's not clear cutie how to
use that pawn because it's the pawn e3 and it does
protect the knight but as the game continues
you need to create past pawns and try to win
um uh i think my my next move here would just
to bring that that rook to c1 to attack that
queen okay that's why benji moved off but rook
to see one is still yeah take over the open file
and it's not easy for uh for white to figure out
a way to press forward because you want to push
your pawns but if you start pushing your pawn
to f3 that could potentially create weaknesses
around your king so any pawn push you make
that's a permanent decision because pawns
can't move backwards and his his pawn structure
in front of his king is just a complete complete
barricade they seem to both be kind of tiptoeing
around an idea here like both kind of avoiding
yeah they're playing a little copycat but they
make sense because they're fighting for an open
file and black and double the default or black
can bring the rook to c8 and try to use the c
file so both sides are doing the right thing
as there are two open files next to each other
they're trying to figure out which one is
best to operate on i do with wish shardosh
would use his other rook that rook being
tucked in that corner is making me very sad
so you think that his next move is
just going to be bringing the rook over
i hope so i think that's gonna be his move i
think i'll play it pretty quickly there it is
there it is okey dokey and benji down one pawn
but now down two minutes and there's no clear
plan for black you just kind of have to sit tight
and ask sardis what are you going to do to beat
me in this position because you only have one
pawn and neither of us are attacking the other
so you know cutie these positions i think
are some of the most difficult in chess
yeah the it's interesting this time
deficit is the biggest it's ever been
over two minutes and well do you think that benji
you know he can handle it he is obviously an uh
amazing esporter can we call him that how
would he call it yeah he's an e he's a
yeah he's an east esport esport player e
athlete just an athlete okay we can just call
it an athlete oh okay you just told me that ludwig
wore these same sweatpants for four days in a row
that doesn't sound like an athlete well his excuse
was why change if you're gonna get him dirty again
so maybe he's just smart he's honest
maybe he's onto something yeah potential
it looks like sardosh is now in the think tank
here trying to come up with an actual plan rather
than just making you know good moves and it's
important to do so but you need plans behind your
moves and this knight e4 well placed by benji if
he plays pawn f3 down goes this g3 pawn you don't
want to drop a pawn in this position but he needs
to figure out how to push forward from this point
and it's really not clear i think these are some
of the hardest positions qd and chess to play
because there's no checkmate attack to go
with there's no weakness that's clearly
yeah it's very scary right i'm happy to
see sardo really really thinking this out
yeah he brings his queen back to e1 so i think
he's trying to protect this pawn on g3 so
that maybe he can play f3 next and kick this
knight out and he doesn't drop the pawn here
i don't know it's uh an interesting idea and i
think that's what i would do i'm always gonna just
agree with whatever you say yeah what did what
did he just do oh he just dropped his queen down
interesting you don't have to agree with me come
on well i don't know stonewall i should not be
agreeing it's too late to do the stonewall it's
absolutely too late i didn't mean to bring up
i don't understand why you think how the
stonewall is played at the end game but
it's not it's an opening it's an opening hess i
will learn one day i was just going to say that
i don't know everything chess players make
mistakes we're human you know things happen
and i didn't mean to bring up the stonewall again
so no more stonewall for me but this rook is under
attack so so that's scary yes don't want that
it's very very scary i wonder goodness there's no
there's no checks here i just don't i i don't know
what i would do i think i would just move the rook
and keep tiptoeing around i don't know what to
do here and that's probably what you should do
and you say you don't know what to do and well you
need to move away for starters but let's say you
bring the rook back and the knight comes back to
attack your rook you're gonna have to do something
otherwise we'll just be repeating you're just
gonna be repeating yeah but then that equals a
draw correct that would be a draw which black you
know benji's up one uh point here he wants to draw
and sardoch of course wants to play for a win yeah
i would take a draw yeah so i think sardosh is
going to switch the files of his rook so instead
of keeping the rook on the d file he'll go rook c2
and rook c1 and the reason why is this pawn
defends this knight so you don't need your
rooks on this file they can happily shift to the c
file and try to go for a breakthrough on that line
oh this is just so stressful and while the players
are feeling it benji down under four minutes
and you see that sardosh four minutes 40 seconds
a bit of a lead on the clock white is upon
ahead he just needs to come up with a plan and
another idea that i'm just coming up with here
and he plays f3 which keeps yeah keeping that
knight out maybe he can push the pawn himself
but i was also looking at a b4 b5 push so
you can get the c6 square for your knight
you can anchor that knight in on a more
advanced square not out of the question so
not easy to play this seriously cutie it's
just every single move you need to figure
out what's my opponent thinking are they actually
threatening anything it seems like no but you can
be lulled into a false sense of security and
then that's when the biggest mistakes happen
i think i think benji's next move here
is it too soon to get your king involved i don't
know when when in the end game is it too soon to
get your king involved it's a good question i
think with the queens on the board it's a bit
too soon okay because if the king goes towards the
center black or white whoever's king is going to
center there are enough pieces remaining to start
attacking that king and so i think benji is just
trying to poke and prod brings the queen to a6
the queen on b7 was just shut down by this pawn f3
so now there's an attack on the pawn here
the queen you know has some nice open scope
not that it amounts to much it's an empty diagonal
but at least it can pretend to do something
you seem deep and conscious uh
i'm looking at i'm looking at this
his night and i'm curious and again chad i'm just
i'm giving a much lower perspective here okay i'm
900 rated i'm just going to say that knight moving
there because then it's looking at that bishop
and now the queen's not
there to protect the bishop
right the rooks here rook rook i get
bishop and rook confused i don't know why
i got you covered i knew exactly what you meant
and there are actually some devious threats
here that black needs to be very careful about
because i could see this ending in a checkmate
pretty soon for white here it goes after queen
takes queen takes a2 if you take this in comes
the queen of d8 with check and after king h7
there's knight e7 trying to bring the queen here
and checkmate this king and there's big
danger for black this could be very scary okay
let's see wait check okay 97 oh my gosh oh oh
no watch out here so the move that black should
play is push your f-pawn because benji's queen is
actually eyeing the g8 square through the pawn so
push that pawn up the board oh wow and you can
save the day you can save the day here and look at
benji deep in thought what a cool mate i love any
mates with with a knight i think they're very cool
this you really don't see this very often but it's
because black's pieces are all out over there on
the queen side not helping the king and you're
asking you know when can you bring the king out
not in this position even a queen at night that's
enough material to land a checkmating attack
so this is very scary for benji he's
thinking he needs to push the pawn
i think that there's no other way to save the
king besides pushing the pawn up the board
i hope he sees it i don't i don't i i think he
will just because he's surprised me a few times
and you know he's desperately looking right now
you know that he knows that there's got to be a
way and he could be thinking about pushing
the pawn up to make space for the king the
problem is the queen will stop on g8 then go to
h8 and this king is going on a walk up the board
and actually checkmated in the next move after
queen takes pawn so let's show that very quickly
if h5 queen g8 up keep check it's force checkmate
there's nothing that black can do and that would
be a checkmate wow let's see no move yet no move
played by ben oh he's got a minute come on veggie
oh and he's not streaming so we can't see oh
oh no it's gonna be this exact checkmate it's
going to be the checkmate here comes sodor sees
it no question he's going to do this mate oh boy
oh boy oh oh he blew the queen oh my oh my
gosh you blunted the queen does benji see
it does benji see it benji do you see this oh he
has to see it look at benji's face he's in shock
oh he took the queen and sardosh loses the
queen benji is so confused he's smiling
no the tragedy not the queen oh oh my god benji
is smiling sardosha's melting he's melting oh no
played a great game and that's so frustrating in
chess you play a fantastic game he was playing so
well and on one turn doesn't see the queen on the
opposite the board full board awareness needs to
see these things and unfortunately for sodos he
is laughing at himself he is laughing at himself
at least he's not crying well it's a botez gambit
for the ages and benji fishy wins the group
a great match by benji but did get the benefit
of that blunder there both of these players look
like serious contenders and benji fishy
wins the group two nothing in this match
what more is there to say cutie i just
i'm just i i'm so proud of benji you know
he just feels like my new best friend and i've
been rooting for him this whole time and so
he is going to teach me play fortnite
and then i'll make millions of dollars
quick question so levy was your best friend just
like a couple minutes ago and now benji's your
best friend dude i'll say it [ __ ] levy
i hate that guy oh okay well before he can
mulled in the chat let's go to our final break
we'll be back with the players in just a few
took another second to not blunder his queen
but absolutely nuts play oh [ __ ] uh wait uh
french surrendering again oh looks like
only one frenchman took down the w today
oh it was me was it nuts only room for one
of these tournaments son and it's not you
by the way interestingly i looked at the bracket
and what this now means is that uh the winner
of group a is benji fishy so he's going to
be here sardoche will be here uh and then
who wins between me and charlie will dictate
whether we're on sardoshi's or benji's side
i don't know if i really want either to be
honest but here's the dangerous part whoever
loses with me and charlie on sunday will
almost assuredly be playing rayne wilson
which is [ __ ] terrifying because we play the
winner of group c for second place so if i lose
to charlie tomorrow i would have to beat rayne
wilson and then presumably uh i would have to play
benji fishy if he keeps going on the path
he's going on so this side of the bracket
is [ __ ] this is rayne wilson and benjy fishy
this side of the bracket i think is a bit easier
i think it's a bit easier it would be uh depending
on who wins between me and charlie and then
like daniel negranu uh maybe if xqc loses
you know i'm not too worried sardosh
you know i'm not worried about that so we'll
see we'll see it's gonna be a tight bracket
i regret winning i wish i could just go to
the consolation bracket you make more money
for getting first in the consolation
than last in the [ __ ] championship
it's horse [ __ ] everyone's
too cracked at this [ __ ] game
i put it so many hours give me a easy bracket
for once chess.com stop giving me this 16 year
old cracked ass kids i can't handle it just let me
have a freebie one time in my life i'm losing it
if i lose to 16 year old i'm gonna i'm gonna
cry i will cry live on stream i'll never
stream again and not to be ageist but i'm 25.
and i've been like practicing for like a year
do i at least have more subscribers on youtube
than benji fishy what did i do with these nine
extra [ __ ] years what have i done what was
the point of having nine extra years i don't
this is [ __ ] is he tall don't tell me
he's also tall is he tall bendy fishy height
let's go let's go
suck it benji suck it
god picked me
oh that's justice but seriously if i lose
to someone who wasn't even alive for 9 11
that's [ __ ] up he's 16 yeah good
i hope he doesn't grow until 17.
i don't care what he does after
i'm not in a tournament with him
all right this is the small temporal of time
that i care about i just need to be taller
than him in this like hopefully he doesn't
have a summer growth spurt that's all i care
and we're back with both players benji fishy
wins two nothing over sardosh both of you played
amazingly well i have to say that i think this was
the closest match and the best played match of the
entire event so benji i want to start with you can
you just tell everybody what you've been doing how
much you've been practicing and it is clearly
paying off uh yeah i've been practicing as much
as i can uh you know i've got like fortnight
tournaments but you know whenever i have spare
time um i i just really enjoy playing it's a
this is a nice hobby of mine i i just really
enjoy and i want to i'm a competitive guy so i
want to get you know as good as possible at it
for sure and so what about you um every time i
open twitch you're playing chess or studying with
a new coach seems like you're taking this very
seriously and you did play great chess of course
both games ended on what's you know look
like blunders in your end but you were really
playing well throughout well i i don't know
i first of all it was one of my intense game
uh i played for my whole life so i wasn't
used to be focused for so long in a chess game
for at first and then well i i'm a bit sad
because i lost bot game boss game because of
tactics i was supposed to be slightly worse
than benji concerning positional stuff and close
position because he used to close the position and
uh i used to open up i play an open silent play
well i couldn't play my stuff and he trained he
prepared very well against my london system so
i i was a bit confused at first but i always
managed to get out of the first position
better and i get too confident i guess so
i'm super i'm super ashamed actually to
that i have done this mistake because i
already expected to win this tactic and
no you played amazing and i know obviously the
result stings but i have to reiterate that time
and time again you really played excellent even
in this moment i brought up the boarder you're
talking about positional uh benji you kind of
locked the position this bishop on b7 was stuck
here but i like the way you both played this first
you sardosh bringing the knight to d7 excellent
move and then benji instead of taking this knight
you brought your knight back keeping as close as
possible so kind of what was your thought process
like at this position benji i'll start with you
um i wanted to to get rid of this night basically
and i i don't know i didn't really like my night
being there uh or like my well i didn't like his
night being there so i was like oh i might as well
just try and get it out and then try attacking
his king sides uh since i'd the the queen side
like locked basically all closed uh yeah that was
basically not too much for processing it but yeah
such a casual way to articulate your thought
on such an intense game plan like holy cow
yeah and i mean and so those on your end
of things and after this trade sequence
everything started to improve at this moment where
benji you had the right idea but it was a little
bit too soon because after the capture which soros
did perfectly and the move bishop seat really hard
move to play generally speaking dropping your
bishop back but sotos did you consider this move
um uh honestly uh i i didn't really consider it
because i felt like it would just run away and
uh i will lose tempo i don't know uh first of all
i i told you you would take with the bishop and
i was able to take this pawn on e5 and then open
up the position but he did the right thing taking
with his uh well with the brochure oh yeah yeah
and you had the right idea g6 is a good move it
just so happens that bishop c would have kept
your pawn structure a little safer because in
the next few moves we saw what happened with rook
f5 that was a nice tactical shot by you uh benji
whereas point the rook on f8 walked into this pin
but still you follow really well with bishop a6
just to immediately okay i may have lost the pawn
but let me go on the attack myself so benjamin
uh quick question for you did you see the
bishop retreat that you could play this or
will you thinking that bishop was an attacking
piece and kind of overlooked that it could come
back to your defense yeah i i didn't see that
i'm gonna be honest i didn't see that i can't
i didn't see it actually i kind of just i was
opening it after this i was like oh i'm about
to lose one out of bricks i'm like i need to try
and i know just look for a checkmate i mean okay
so i guess it worked but i got pretty lucky to be
honest um i'm just i'm happy i i did it i saw it
at least i'm happy i saw the checkmate yeah it was
really nice and it's i was saying to cudi during
the commentary that it's really difficult these
are the hardest things to think about is backwards
you know these retreating moves especially when
your bishop just took a pawn and came in the
attack but this would have saved material and
sadosha and i know this is going to be painful
but at this point here you end up taking on
c5 what was your thought process what were you
calculating and what was it that you overlooked i
don't know i i completely miscalculated the queen
could actually follow up and well it's so stupid
because i just have to push my pawn on the e
on dnc and i could just win the game i guess i
could just close up the position stall he was
close in time so i could just push my opponent and
play the final will be quite an easy final i think
um i'm not sure maybe i was well i i think i had a
lead but i don't know both games i missed tactics
maybe because i woke up too early i'm tired and
it just plays so well it pushed me to my last uh
my last uh wants of energy i was like i was like
too it just played where i i had to blunder at
some points and he played so so perfect during
all that time and i honestly prod i lost in
game like this well my blunder are something
but overall i think games were really really
great and we showed up some grits we just show up
that europe is better than an a in the structure
okay yeah i mean in in the second game starters
you were one move away from checkmating yeah man
i just took the opponent and said okay he
can't actually uh remove i will mat in one
no matter what so i will play it the safe way
i i actually imagined the the combo with knight
and i felt like okay this is too complicated uh
i will focus on super thing just take the and
treat the mat in one and i didn't see the queen
in my head queen was attacking so it couldn't
she couldn't be able to defend for some reason
i i break up the board in two pieces and
i completely know that they could come back and
so then i think that's the theme of both games
honestly with retreating moves are very hard
to see so it's something just uh to check for
on both iran's and serge i mean you should keep
your head held high you were one move away from
evening the match and it felt like a very back and
forth struggle so i think you both should be proud
of the way you played but i think i did a mistake
in the white game at the end because i needed to
kick off the night before going for my place
with uh because if i don't do that i believe he
will just take my opponent and ignore my i think
when he took the rook it was a mistake actually
um because he could just told because he
has bishop and rook covering the pieces
so he had three pawn basically and i i
was summoned at myself when i missed uh
it was maybe b5 or or before to kick off the
the night and yeah well i didn't pay perfect but
we will meet up again i think this year yeah i
think so too you did really well you need to give
yourself more credit you keep talking about how
well benji played but you played out of your mind
yeah you really did and you won't have a chance
to meet again i don't think unless you meet in
the finals you'll be on the opposite sides of the
bracket so you can avoid each other for the time
being and i mean benji huge congrats and so the
highest rated player in the field at this point
it felt like a really intense struggle of both
parts what are you planning to do as you both
head into the championship bracket uh i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna keep playing you know i mean
it's not i'm just gonna keep doing what i've been
doing uh it works pretty good you know i'm getting
coached uh every day by hammer which is helping
a lot um i think i'm improving uh really fast and
yeah hopefully we can meet again in the final
also benji i heard that you're actually six three
which is four inches taller than ludwig is that
true that that is correct yeah right very cool
correcting the uh the height out there that people
are googling and putting out but um i know it's
gonna sting for a bit but what's your plan how
do you recover from this i mean you obviously had
painful losses in your life before but so how do
you bounce back honestly first of all uh i wasn't
confident with my opening uh my black opening it
was maybe the first time i played it in a game
because i didn't find spring partner to play that
i just knew the theory oh i needed to play against
the english opening so i need to train it a bit
more if i want to match uh benji because i wasn't
playing perfect in my opinion and soon while i i
would just play and try to grind uh i just want
to say one thing because most of the people in the
english cast told that i was actually coached by
maxim vashilagar but it's not true he's actually
full triading with the chain backrow for the
candidate tournament so he has actually no time
to talk with me or help me and i would love to but
sadly he's not up for that so if you heard that
maxim is helping me it's not true i'm basically
playing a lot of game alone and nemsco and kevin
uh body are helping me a lot for this so i will
try to make them proud in the next game and with
my best in quarter finals and i open it again
well i think they definitely are proud and
honestly it was me starting the false rumors
i heard that maxine was somehow in the bunch
my my apologies for the mistake but you know
the coaching is working for both of you hammer on
your end benji and for nemsco and for blitzstream
i mean clearly it's working everybody was
so excited to see the progress you two are
making so i think you both should be proud of
yourselves and i know your coaches are proud
of you as well so uh cutie any final thoughts
no things to say you know no mean things to say
sardosh i am going to apologize on behalf of my
boyfriend ludwig who keeps calling you sardoush
you are not a douche i want you to know that
you're very sweet and you're good at chess
thanks let's go and beat ludwig so he can
stop calling you that whoa you got to put
him in the place sometimes clearly i've chosen
your favorites here and benji actually cutie
was betting money on you so yeah i won ten dollars
on you benji thank you very much no worries i got
you all right you two have a good one thanks for
joining us thank you all right wow that was really
wholesome i mean i kind of feel really badly
for sardosh right now he seems despondent he's
just crushed by those games and he had that second
game he was just right there away from checkmate
he was so close and blundered the queen at the end
so that 2-0 score not represented how this match
was it was really close should have been one
to one just at the finish line there and benji
he sees the tactics when he needs
them and is able to win the match 2-0
it was good it was good game it was a tough game
i'm excited to i'm excited to keep watching both
of them and we will see them in the championship
racket we don't know yet who they will play but
we know that benji fishy is the top seed out
of that group he gets a couple extra thousand
dollars for winning the group and for sardosh he's
upset he'll bounce back he's playing great chess
that result to me you know as somebody who coaches
it's something that you can ignore as a coach
and say no the way you played was excellent and i
hope that he just continues the push because he's
already strong player and we'll just get stronger
and there's another fun event after hog champs
there is the twitch rivals hand in brain march
2nd 1pm pacific time you don't want to tune in on
twitch.tv twitch rivals going to be many of your
favorite streamers taking part in what is going
to be a fantastic event and cutie tomorrow we have
some great matchups that we've highlighted before
any predictions for those uh pokemane will win
everything um anything she touches will equal a w
i think rain and logic i think rain will take
it um and xqc i think xqc will take us his uh
1 40 p.m match against daniel negroni
who has won both of his matches thus
far so he i mostly said that because i
couldn't pronounce daniel's last name
the honesty is appreciated well daniel has won
both matches thus far xqc is won his only match
played against rubius so we'll see if x2cc can
take down the leader of that group and pokeyman
and ecstasy will end the day facing off against
one another in the postpo match it has been a real
fun time i mean i had a great time commenting with
you i don't know i had a great time i will never
be invited back but we were we were happy to be
here i'm glad i think you will be invited back
your regular chess streams are highly enjoyable
so yeah well thank you your spot on the commentary
it was nice to be here it was nice to see you guys
it was nice hanging out chat you guys you guys are
doing great you guys have gotten nicer i have
nothing to talk to you about today no lectures
um i appreciate your growth chess chat all right
well i guess i have some things to lecture about
chess related but that's oh [ __ ] another time
another thing and arena kings will begin at 4 pm
pacific that's in 25 minutes from now and hikara
will be playing and you will want to tune into
his stream gm hikaru obviously one of the best
chess players on the planet an amazing streamer
so he will be playing in that event and then in
a couple hours from now i will continue my just
crazy day of chess commentary i will be covering
the corporate chess championships the world's
different corporations a lot of chess
to be had a lot of things to learn and
beauty i mean those are my final thoughts i'll
hand you over i'll hand it over to you the sign
off here um well thanks everyone for coming
out we'll see you tomorrow with some more
matches and four o'clock arena keens very very
excited um yeah if you guys ever want to watch
me play chess poorly i play every tuesday
and thursday at 8pm i not not poorly you're
playing well i have definitely support you
there and just remind everybody as well that
you know this is an event raising money for
various charities of the players choices so
if you can if you're able to please uh do donate
it goes to a great cause and that note this
is the end of today's coverage of politicians
three presented by grip six we'll see you soon
uh
oh
ripple
ricky there is